[Musique]
quentin Müller bonsoir bonsoir nous vous
recevons pour une chaîne internet qui
s'appelle servview nous sommes en
direct on a dit est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter sucintement d'abord donc
moi je suis journaliste j'ai le magazine
Marianne il y a 8 mois en tant que
rédacteur en chef adjoint du service
international pendant 10 ans j'ai
bourlingué au Moyen-Orient tant que
pigiste donc j'ai travaillé dans la
péninsule arabique en Irak en Iran en
Afrique de l'Est donc sur des
destinations qui sont pas toujours très
recommandables mais c'est pas c'est pas
ce que je cherche moi je suis avant tout
un reporter et pas un reporter de guerre
et donc mon chemin petit à petit m'a
amené un peu par hasard euh au Yémen et
je suis tombé amoureux de de ce pays
littéralement il y a il y a maintenant 4
ans j'y suis allé plusieurs fois en 2021
en 2022 en
2023 malgré la la la grande difficulté
pour accéder à ce pays totalement fermé
depuis le début de la guerre civile en
2014 et je peux dire qu'aujourd'hui je
suis je me suis spécialisé sur ce pays
je suis pas devenu un grand spécialiste
mais mais je suis tellement tombé en
pamoison devant devant devant le Yemen
qu'aujourd'hui je me qualifie comme
comme un journaliste spécialisé sur le
le Yémen et il y en a pas beaucoup en
France kouutamam
kouamam donc on a décidé de vous faire
venir aujourd'hui pour parler du Yémen
de la péninsule arabique de parler
scandale écologique et pas que
écologique sanitaire humain sanitaire
humain et tout ce qui va avec et
peut-être
économique qu'est-ce qui se passe au
Yémen qu'est-ce qui se passe avec les
outils qu'est-ce qui qui se passe avec
le pays comment ça se fait que on en
arrive à avoir une population qui est
considérée comme pirate coupe qui coupe
les câbles internet qui target qui cible
des des navires en mer Rouge qu'est-ce
qui se passe en terme industriel sur
place qu'est-ce qui se passe en terme
scandale énergétique sanitaire
économique je vous laisse choisir par
quoi commencer
c'est c'est une longue histoire là
j'espère qu'on a plusieurs heures parce
que on n pas là pour pousser un CAD
ouais mais alors ça c'est ça ça ça va
être long alors ok on
commence par une anecdote votre maman
vous avez quel âge j'ai 31 ans votre
maman quand vous lui dites bon ma maman
je vais au Yémen aujourd'hui quelle tête
elle fait comment vous la préparé
psychologiquement mais c'est pas c'est
pas ma mère qui s'inquiète le plus c'est
mon père paradoxalement et pourtant il a
beaucoup voyagé dans sa vie il a fait
des des voyages que même moi j'ai pas
fait en terme de d'insécurité mais c'est
lui qui s'inquiète le plus moi ma mère
bon ça va je lui dis je vais là je vais
là elle me dit bon je te fais confiance
ça va bon malgré ça sur certaines
destinations je l'aurais pas dit où
j'allais tout le temps je lere disais
quand je rentrais chez moi enfin une
fois arrivé à l'aéroport à Paris en
disant bon voilà je reviens de de ce
pays-là donc parfois pour pas trop les
inquiéter parce que j'aime j'aime pas
inquiéter mon entourage j'aime pas
sentir que enfin avoir aussi cette
culpabilité de de de de créer des
sensations désagréables pour mes proches
donc j'aime pas ça donc plusieurs fois
ça m'est arrivé de de leur cacher mes
mes destinations votre femme elle est au
courant alors j'ai pas de femme votre
Pax votre ami euh j'ai eu j'ai eu des
compagnes qui savaient que je partais
ici et là bon après c'est c'est ça me
regarde ça c'est est-ce que vous est-ce
que vous prévenez le kéorset quand vous
allez vous balader là-bas non surtout
pas pourquoi surtout pas le kéorsy j'ai
déjà eu des problèmes avec le kéorset en
Irak ça m'est arrivé une fois où à
l'ambassade j'arrive à Bagdad
l'ambassade m'appelle en disant oui
Quentin müer je sais que vous venez
j'aimerais vous rencontrer qu'on parle
un peu du pays donc je me moi naïf je
vais je rencontre un un diplomate qui
est brillant on parle d'irac pendant une
heure et puis à la fin il me demande un
peu les sujets que je vais évoquer après
m'avoir bien amadoué et moi je lu dis
alors moi j'ai envie d'aller là j'ai
envie j'ai envie de faire ça et je
voulais rencontrer des tribus au nord
des tribus sunites qui hébergeit enfin
qui s'était battu contre daesh et et ses
tribus étaient encore aujourd'hui
harcelé par des cellules dormantes du
groupe terroriste et donc c'était un peu
une zone crgos mais bon moi j'avais la
l'assurance que les tribus allaient me
protéger et donc il me fallait des
autorisations pour me rendre dans ces
zones-là délivré par le gouvernement
iraakien très facile à obtenir
normalement et là il se trouve que je
lui explique ce ce sujet-là euh et il me
dit à la fin bon ben vous partez quand
vous rentrez quand à Paris je lui donne
ma date du retour et comme par hasard
j'ai j'ai obtenu mes autorisations le
jour de de mon départ pour pour Paris et
je suis persuadé que le kedoré enfin le
le l'ambassadeur ou un diplomate a
appelé les autorités iraakiennes pour ne
pas me donner mes autorisations en tout
cas les donner le jour où je partais je
rentrais à Paris donc ça j'en suis ça je
sais et je sais que les le kadoré fait
tout sur les zones à risque pour que les
journalistes français ne fassent pas
leur travail euh et pour les empêcher en
fait de prendre des risques et d'être
d'être emmerdé moi je me souviens très
bien d' une interview que j'avais faite
aussi avec l'ambassadeur français à
Kabou je le rend compre la première
chose qu'il me dit c'est n'alllez pas
dans les zones ici et là parce que nous
on n pas envie de nous emmerder à aller
vous chercher en plus c'est l'été c'est
les
vacances m pas pour la maison voilà
voilà c'est ça donc bon je suis pas le
seul journaliste à le dire donc le Kedor
j'ai aucune
confiance ça fait mal quand même
d'entendre ça c'est pas que ça fait mal
c'est une c'est une réalité qui est
claire moi j'ai pas confiance en mes
autorités quand je travaille dans dans
ces pays-là après je sais que mon pays
dans certaines situations fera tout pour
me me me libérer si jamais je venais
être
arrêté ou ou si j'avais des problèmes ça
m'est jamais arrivé en 10ant j'ai jamais
demandé de l'aide de auocadoré en 10 an
vous souscrivez une assurance médiateur
une assurance négociateur qu vous partez
ou
votre rédaction souscrit une assurance
pour vous ou pas alors pendant 10 ans
j'ai été pigiste donc pigiste on gagne
très peu ave les les reportages sont mal
rémunérés j'ai jamais pris aucune
assurance et d'ailleurs il y a jamais
aucune assurance qui n'accepterait de
m'assurer pour partir en Somalie en
Afghanistan en Irak au Yémen comme enfin
dans c'est dans ces pays où moi j'ai pu
aller et donc les assurances ne vous
suivent pas dans ces cas-là ou alors
faut payer une somme astronomique quand
vous partez sur place sur place vous
prenez un visa touristique ou
professionnel en fait ça dépend des des
destinations il y a des pays où on peut
pas partir en visa touriste il y a pas
de visa touriste ça existe pas l'Irak
pendant très longtemps il y avait pas de
visa touriste donc j'étais obligé de
passer par l'ambassade obligé de me
présenter en tant que journaliste la
Somalie y a pas de visa touriste non
plus j'étais embarqué avec une une une
une ONG le Yémen il y a pas de visa
touriste non plus euh l'Iran ça m'est
arrivé plusieurs fois de travailler en
visa touriste et à chaque fois c'est
j'étais à deux doigts de de de me faire
arrêter d'ailleurs je suis allé dans les
périodes qui étaient plutôt favorables
parce que il y avait un accord sur le
nucléaire qui était conclu avec les
États-Unis avec avec la France donc il y
avait une détente euh et ça m'a empêché
je pense de de d'aller en d'aller en
prison puce que je me suis fait arrêter
une fois en Iran interrogé je pense par
des passes d'Arran et et à ce moment-là
euh on a pris mon passeport pendant une
journée on m'a filmé j'ai eu un
interrogatoire et on m'a libéré et je
pense que si on m'a libéré c'est qu'à
l'époque il y avait une détente entre le
le le le monde occidental et l'Iran
aujourd'hui je pense que j'aurais pu
être emprisonné et servir de monnaie
d'échange avec des tour avec des
prisonniers iraniens ou pour dégeler des
avoirs ici et là de de chef militaire
pass d'Aron ça ressemble à quoi un
interrogatoire iranien c'est c'est un
entretien de la BAC dans le 93 ou c'est
un peu plus musclé alors c'est c'est
beaucoup plus subtile qu' l'entretien de
la BAC c'est-à-dire que c'est vous déjà
été entretenu par la BAC non mais je
enfin j'ai déjà vu des films voilà mais
alors l'Iran en Iran c'est on on vient
vous chercher avec des types en civil
les types ont des gueules un peu qui
font
peur des cernes des visages un peu
cassés des donc on vient vous chercher
et puis on vous dit vous inquiétez pas
c'est pour votre sécurité ça c'est un
impondérable on vous prend votre
passeport toujours c'est pour faire des
vérifications pour votre sécurité et euh
et ensuite euh on passe dans des espèces
de méandes on arrive dans des
préfabriqués et quand les civils passent
devant des militaires qui sont là les
militaires font le garde à vousout et là
on se dit on n'est pas avec n'importe
qui on n'est pas avec des policiers
lambda et ensuite donc on vous met dans
une
salle vide et dans cette salle vide il y
a 40 mecs 40 mecs qui font tout le tour
de la salle et qui sont debout qui vous
regardent il y a un seul type qui est
assis à un bureau avec une une page
blanche il y a l'interprète qui est à
ses côtés qui est toujours très gentil
et la première chose qu'on vous dit
c'est
question question et de manière assez
ferme et vous vous répondez où sont les
clopes où est le
café non malheureusement c'est pas dans
dans ces momentsl on est tout rouge on
va pas très très bien on est un peu
inquiet mais il faut faire bonne figure
puisqueon est touriste on n'est pas
espion on n'est pas journaliste donc
faut faire le touriste un peu effarouché
mais qu'est-ce qui se passe mais
pourquoi je comprends pas ma femme m'a
appelé non pas ma femme m'a appelé
surtout pas mais non à ce moment-là faut
garder faut faut faire bonne figure faut
être zen et surtout faut avoir révisé sa
sa légende en fait parce que avant de
partir faut avoir un peu créé une une
histoire qui raconterait le ton parcours
touristique et qui raconterait comment
tu as déjà rencontré auparavant ton ton
collègue enfin qui est censé être ton
ami et donc il se trouve que mon
collègue photographe je le connaissait
pas du tout et que on s'était inventé
une histoire de comment on s'était
rencontré notre amitié depuis quand et
cetera donc on a on a on a pu faire à
peu près bonne figure mais c'est des
interrogatoires qui durent plus d'une
heure ou où on me pose des questions sur
mon mon mon cousin comment il s'appelle
avec qui je joue au foot à l'école des
des questions totalement barges et dans
ces cas-là faut faut faut répondre du
tac au tac faut bah avoir rien à cacher
et il faut quand on donne un mensonge
c'est toujours un demi-msonge c'est
toujours un mensonge on peut se
rattraper aux branches au cas où il y a
euh
au cas où on se fait démasquer mais dire
non non mais en fait on on dévie en fait
à ce moment-là et puis on ce
demi-mensonge se transforme finalement
une vérité donc c'est c'est comme ça
qu'il faut je pense réagirors ça va ils
ont dissipé le ouais mais après on m' on
nous a gardé pendant toute la journée
avec des gens qui qui se mettaient
derrière nous avec un petit camescope et
en nous filmant très étrange he sans
nous demander nous dire pourquoi les
passeports sont gardés les gens sont au
Toki walkie âge 24 et surtout la chose
qui m'a fait le plus flipper c'est que
j'avais mon mon traducteur qui était un
petit jeune que j'avais connu depuis peu
un iranien et et un type vient avec des
cernes pas poss possible une gueule
monumentale enfin bref il vient lui
prend le bras et lui chotte un truc à
l'oreille et je vois les larmes monté
dans les yeux de de mon traducteur et là
je me dis on est dans la merde on est
vraiment dans la merde parce que là
c'est pas ces questions sont pas noodine
et surtout là ce qu'il vient de lui dire
c'est c'est certainement très grave et
donc à ce moment-là on sait pas quoi
faire quoi et et moi j'étais un bleu
j'étais en 2015 je venais de débuter ma
carrière ça faisait plus d'un an et demi
que j'étais journaliste donc j'avais pas
des réflexes extraordinaires de Sécur FO
ça souv ouais ouais ou enfin bon là
j'étais naïf j'étais nul et il se trouve
que dans mon sac dans ma sacoche j'avais
des des coupures de presse sur les
passes d'Aran euh donc l'armée secrète
iranienne et puis j'avais comme un con
j'avais programme d' marche non pire que
ça j'avais gardé un vieux Charlie hebbdo
et les Iraniens n'aiment pas trop
charlierd alors c'était pas la
caricature du prophète heureusement
parce que alors là j'étais j'étais pendu
mais donc j'ai demandé au bout de la au
bout d'une heure d'interrogatoire
d'aller pisser et avec ma ma
sacoche je suis accompagné par un
militaire on arrive à une espèce de
chiotte turque
dégueulasse je fais des des
boulettes et mais j'arrive avec une
grosse boulettes de papier quoi à un
moment donné euh il faut une chasse
d'eau qui fonctionne pour éliminer ce
trucl évidemment comme dans les films la
chasse d'eau fonctionne pas je fais ça
sac d'eau il y a rien qui sort il y a
pas d'eau et cetera bon ben qu'est-ce
que j'ai dû faire j'ai dû chier sur les
les les boulettes de papier d'
d'enfoncer dans le trou pour qu'on ne
voit pas qu'il a cette boulette de
papier bon c'était hyper désagréable ça
a duré une demi-heure je pense que si
ils ont pris pour unansessortant avec ta
main droiteine ouais bah il a pas vu le
militaire je me suis lavé ça il y avit
pas de savon c'était une horreur enfin
bref mais surtout ça avait duré et
j'étais parti au toilett avec ma sacoche
donc les mecs étaient pas cons et et ce
qui s'est passé c'est que le miracle
c'est qu'ils nous ont relâché à la fin
de journée ils sont rendu nos passeports
et ils ont continué à chuchouter dans
l'oreille de mon traducteur et dès que
on avait quitté le poste mon traducteur
m'a dit mais les gars vous on est foutu
ils nous ont dit que dans ils m'ont dit
dans l'oreille que toi tuétais un espion
enfin que les deux là les deux Français
qui bergers c'étaaient des espions que
lui le grand le faut photographe bah on
allait l'électrocuter et lui le petit
moi on allait lui mettre la tête dans
les chiottes donc simulac de Noyan pour
pour les faire avouer et que ils
allaient revenir cette nuit il leur a
donné son adresse et et moi j'attendais
à ce que les Iraniens il viennent me
prendre dans la nuit j'avais fait mon
sac j'avais envoyé un mail à mon père
mais alors attention un mail où je lui
disais oui on a fait une drôle rencontre
aujourd'hui si tu as pas de nos
nouvelles demain appelle appelle
l'ambassade française bah là là appelle
l'ambassade française et il se trouve
que heureusement ils sont pas venus nous
chercher c'était certainement pour nous
faire peur et et c'est parce que je
pense il y avait à ce moment-là les
accords sur le nucléaire qui venait
d'être signé et il voulait pas avoir des
prisonniers des prisonniers occidentaux
bon bah c'est une bonne mise en bouche
on va pouvoir commencer notre interview
ouais ça pas toujours été comme ça hein
mais ma ma carrière heureusement c'est
il y a eu deux trois petits moments de
flip mais ça jamais été 2è c'était quoi
2e alors j'étais arrêté au Yémen et donc
j'ai passé de semaines en en résidence
surveillée mais ça c'est plus tard voilà
pour quelle raison pour quelle raison
euh j'étais donc j'ai tout dire ouais
ben j'étais à sookotra c'est une île au
large du du de la Somalie du Yémen il y
a eu un coup d'État qui a été fait en en
2020 les les une espèce de
d'organisation militaire soutenu par les
Émirats ont pris le le contrôle de lîle
ils ont dégagé le gouverneur et moi en
2021 donc l'année après je suis allé en
tant que cette fois-ci pas ni touriste
mais en tant que professeur de français
j'avais des trouvé une une combine une
combine voilà dans surtout un petit
organisme qui pouvait me prendre en
charge le loyer et cetera et puis je
donnais des vrais cours de français
enfin moi j'ai adoré de être avoir cette
couverture là qui n'était pas vraiment
une couverture puisque mes cours de
français je l'ai préparé avec plaisir et
cetera et donc en à côté de ça j'ai j'ai
fait des investigations sur sur cette
milice qui avait pris en main enfin qui
avait pris le contrôle de lîle sous
couvert de enfin les
émiratsabuni était derrière en fait et
pour des questions stratégiqu et des
questions politiques des sources de ça
ououais bien sûr évidemment j'ai j'ai
écrit plusieurs enquêtes qui ont été
publiées partout et et et donc je suis
retourné après avoir publié ces enquêtes
je suis retourné 2 ans après a donc
l'année dernière en 2023 ils m'ont
laissé travailler pendant un mois sur
place là j'étais venu en tant que
touriste puis après pof ils m'ont chopé
et ils m'ont chopé et ils m'ont montré
tous les articles que j'avais fait et
j'ai été gardé au show pendant 2
semaines on a pris toutes mes affaires
mon
passeport mon appartement là-bas était
tellement insalubre il y avait tellement
de de de de problèmes de coupure
d'électricité on avait pas d'eau que
c'était comme une prison en fait donc
j'ai passé de semaines là-bas sans avoir
de de connexion avec l'extérieur et en
sachant pas si je si j'allais juger si
j'is être mis en prison si on allait
m'expulser et voilà j'ai fini pas être
par être
expulsé vous êtes revenu depuis là-bas
non non est-ce que je vais on va dévier
un peu de de de l'interview mais ça va
être intéressant pour notre communauté
est-ce que vous
comprenez que maintenant quand on est
journaliste ou quand on est au sein
d'une ONG les différents bellig lou vous
regarde de
travers alors oui c'est
normal forcément un
journaliste un un humanitaire ça peut
être une couverture de la
déstabilisation de l'espionnage et
souvent les biligérants dans ces régions
sont un peu paranoau donc donc je peux
comprendre mais et puis surtout il y a
des journalistes les journalistes
étrangers les journalistes même locaux
hein peuvent sortir des enquêtes ou des
témoignages ou des images des vidéos qui
peuvent être compromettantes pour ces
groupes donc et pareil pour quelqu'un
qui travaille pour une ONG cette
personne elle peut parler elle peut
faire une photo donc il y a il y a une
paranoïa notamment au Yemen qui est
énorme envers les les humanitaires
surtout chez les les rebelles
outil est-ce que est-ce que moi je
valide ça non parce que cette paranoïa
elle est tellement accrue qu'il y a des
des humanitaires qui sont passés par la
CE
chez les Rebell outil alors des
humanitaires étrangers je sais pas si
certains ont été assassinés par l'ou je
je ça non mais sont passés par la casse
prison d'autres ont été kidnappés par
alqaïda par exemple ça c'est pour des
questions de de rançon de monnaie
d'échange
d'argent et puis il y en a certains
aussi dans le sud du du pays notamment
un Turc qui a été assassiné ça on m'
avait parl et ça c'était pour des des
questions de soupçon d'espionnage parce
que le sud est tenu par les émirat Arab
Unis ce turc là euh il était soupçonné
par les les les milices qui sont
affiliés aux Émirats de de soutenir les
Frères musulmans qui sont his par les
Émirats arabes unis donc les Frères
musulmans yeménites et donc de part sa
nationalité et ses allé est venu qui
était suspect c'est le mec s'est fait
descendre
donc ça arrive malheureusement et c'est
pas c'est terrible parce que
l'assassinat ou le kidnapping d'un
journaliste ou d'un humanitaire ça
engendre des conséquences qui sont
énormes c'est-à-dire qu'il y a des des
ONG de multiples ONG qui arrêtent leurs
opérations sur place et c'est au dépend
des populations et c'est au dépend de la
formation
aussi bon le Yémen on commence par quoi
une anecdote si vous voulez bien une
anecdote extraordinaire que j'ai lu dans
un bouquin de de deux report porter un
français et gordian troller et Claude La
Farge qui sont partis au Yémen en 62
couvrir la révolution euh c'était un le
nord du pays était totalement hermétique
il y avait un espèce d'imam totalement
dingue qui qui était à la tête du pays
enfin succession d'imam de de familles
différentes et et la médecine éta
interdite le fait de se couper les
cheveux céta interdit de porter des
lunettes et cetera enfin c'est tout
était interdit et donc c'était très très
très très hermétique au monde extérieur
et là les ces deux journalistes partent
en 62 et ils vont couvrir ça et euh et
il
raconte cette anecdote qui pour moi
raconte ce que sont les yeménites et ce
qu'est ce peuple incroyable en fait ils
sont passés par le sud au départ qui
était un protectorat anglais et et les
Anglais avaient tendance à pour acheter
le le le calme et pour pouvoir faire
leur commerce en bateau ils avaient
tendance à acheter le le la prospérité
en en payant des sultans ici et là dès
qu'un soldat anglais avait fait une
connerie dans un des villages et cetera
donc à à compenser financièrement ça en
lâchant de la tune et là il y a un jour
ce bureau des réclamations il y a un
chef de tribu qui vient le voir et qui
fait dans mon village il y a des Anglais
il y a plusieurs années ils sont venus
ils ont tout détruit ils ont cassé les
digs ils ont cassé les champs enfin bref
ils ont fait n'importe quoi je réclame
réclamation je réclame compensation et
là les Anglais euh bah vont vont sur le
site et puis ils regardent dans leurs
archives et puis il y a jamais un
anglais qui a fouler cette terre- làà
quoi donc comme ils veulent faire les
choses bien ils envoient des
archéologues sur place les archéologues
disent que c'était l'Empire romain qui
était y allé qui était allé dans cette
zone-là il y a y a plusieurs siècles et
qui avait effectivement construit euh et
dévasté deux trois villages dans la
région et en fait c'est resté dans la
mémoire collective année enfin succ
enfin famille après famille et euh et
ils ont gardé cette cette histoire là et
ils ont voulu demander réparation
jusqu'à des siècles plus tard et ça
raconte vraiment ce qu'est le le le
Yémen cette anecdote je trouve parce que
l'histoire la géographie pèse sur chaque
chose qui se passe aujourd'hui et et
toutes les la guerre civile qu'on a
aujourd'hui au Yémen qui date qui qui
dure depuis presque bah 10 ans
maintenant bah c'est dû à l'histoire et
c'est là là vous la racontez comme ça je
peux le faire mais il y a tellement
d'éléments historiques et et de vieilles
rancœur de vieilles guerres et cetera
que ça prendrait des plombes
y m il y a du 4at ouais il y a du 4at
alors le mieux c'est les les les petites
feuilles vertes ou les grosses feuilles
vertes foncé alors c'est vous êtes
expert c'est les petites pousses c'est
les petites pousses les grosses feuilles
faut les faut les retirer ouais le 4
c'est tout le monde est sous 4 le 4
c'est une drogue un peu euh
hallucinatoire
énergisante alors on on on perd pas
totalement la la la la la raison quand
on quand on mâche du 4at donc c'est des
petites petites pousses qu'on qu'on
mâche qu'on mâche et on garde une boule
qui devient de plus en plus grosse et en
fait ça ça crée comme un un un absès en
fait et au départ quand on va au yemmen
tout le monde a la boule à droite jamais
à gauche la boule à droite énorme et on
se dit mais ils ont tous des absès les
mecs mais en fait non c'est ils mâchent
tous ce truc au quotidien ce qui leur
donne une énergie de dingue euh mais ce
qui euh leur fait dépenser un fric fou
parce que pour avoir une botte de 4 faut
dépenser au moins 20 € et 20 € c'est
énorme aujourd'hui au Yémen avec
l'inflation la crise économique et
cetera il il y a besoin de bicarbonate
avec ou pas alors ça c'est si on veut
enlever les pesticides ouais parce que
les mecs ils y vont comme des bourrins
en pesticide pour pour cultiver le 4at
mais ouais il faut bien la rincer euh et
moi j'avoue que les premières fois que
je suis allé au Yémen enfin la le
premier jour où j'ai foulé le le sol
yeménite le soir le mec m'a dit allez on
quat et j'ai caté un petit peu pas j'ai
pas eu j'ai pas ressenti trop d'effet
j'ai réessayé plusieurs
fois pas trop non plus mais en fait je
savais pas trop comment m'y prendre et
la fois où j'ai vraiment caté
c'est-à-dire on était tous là dans une
dans une magelice une espèce de salle où
tout le monde s'assoit et là j'ai caté
comme un bourrin pendant 3 heures
j'avais une boule énorme et en fait
j'avais même des des des bobos genscif
parce que force de mâcher avec les
petites les petites branches et cetera
ça fait des ça fait des petits des
petites ouverture au gens mais et et
c'est très acide c'est très amè c'est
c'est pas à bon goût mais là j'ai
vraiment fait l'effort et j'avais une
énergie de dingue j'avais les les les
les les pupilles comme ça ouvertes comme
ça midriaz ah ouais mais j'étais je
ressemblais à un vampire quoi j'étais et
j'avais un courage alors je perdais pas
la raison parce que j'étais je faisais
pas des choses insensées j'avais pas
dépensé insensé mais j'avais un courage
de dingue j'avais une détermination de
fou j'avais une concentration énorme et
j'ai et surtout j'étais prêt à à faire
plein de choses il faut rappeler que
c'est une drogue et qu'on n'incite pas
les gens à prendre de la drogue et c'est
c'est légal là-bas tout mais là-bas
c'est là-bas c'est légal et surtout
c'est culturel c'est-à-dire que si vous
ne Cattez pas avec les gens vous ne
pouvez pas discuter vous ne pouvez pas
rentrer dans l'intimité dans les
informations un peu confidentielles
c'est une manière de de de de
sociabilisé et ça si vous le faites pas
bah journalistiquement vous n'obtenez
pas grand-chose c'est comme les coquiros
en Amérique du Sud ahouais c'est un peu
ça ouais c'est le verre de vin en France
ou la bière bon bah là-bas c'est ça et
et et je me souviens de la nuit que j'ai
passé la première nuit que j'ai passé
après avoir caté bah j'étais comme un
vampire dans mon lit comme ça les bras
en croix ou à regarder le le plafond
impossible de s'endormir et je sais pas
comment les mecs font ils dorment jamais
les yaménites moi je les appelle les les
chauve-souris c'estàdire dire que la
nuit ils sont très actifs et le jour ils
sont ils sont là ils sont plus ou moins
actifs mais et je sais pas comment ils
font parce qu'ils dorment pas ils
dorment pas ils ont des cernes comme ça
et et leur hygiène de vie elle est elle
est elle est dure quoi comment comment
vous voyez
le le ciblage des portes contener en mer
Rouge les atteintes sur les câbles
pourquoi ils font ça les outils les
outils alors déjà qui sont les outils
qui sont les
outils je vais résumer ça de manière
assez
succinte les outils le mouvement outils
est né à la fin des années 90 il y a un
type qui s'appelle Hussein badreddin
alouti qui vient de terminer sa thèse au
Soudan sur un chef zaidit qui est passé
par le Caucase enfin bref un truc un peu
intello et il rentre à Sana dans la
capitale et comme les jeune de sa
génération dans les années 80 90 il
constate quoi que au au fur à mesure que
les années passent il y a de plus en
plus de pays occidentaux qui viennent
grapiller les richesses pétrolières au
Moyen-Orient passe passé les années 90
il y a le 11 septembre qui pass et là le
Moyen-Orient bascule dans une nouvelle
phase
l'invasion américaine en Irak l'invasion
de l'Afghanistan de de l'OTAN dont les
États-Unis et donc beaucoup de
populations arabes ou au Proche Orient
qui qui souffre qui souffre aussi
également d'une politique
américaine de lutte contre le terrorisme
qui va à mon sens beaucoup trop loin
c'est-à-dire que on a des des une lutte
contre le terrorisme qui qui se fait
sans foisilois et qui va jusqu'à tuer
énormément de d'innocents notamment au
Yémen et donc Hussein Badreddine alouti
il fait ce constat là que
cette cette ingérance américaine elle va
beaucoup trop loin vous AZ des preuves
pour les les civils qui ont été tués
sans ouais j'ai fait un un reportage au
Yémen sur le les les erreurs de
d'attaque de drone américaines qui ont
tué énormément de de d'innocents de des
femmes des enfants des gens qui
n'étaient pas du tout absolument pas des
terroristes et qui ont d'ailleurs reçu
parfois des compensations de la part de
de de l'État américain qui sont passés
par des gouverneurs locaux qui ne leur
ont donné aucune compensation financière
au final donc oui oui ça c'est c'est
c'est vraiment documenté je suis pas le
seul à avoir écrit des reportages
là-dessus il y a des rapports aussi qui
ont été écrits au Yémen en Somalie et
dans beaucoup de pays où le terrorisme
était actif et donc je reviens à Husen
badredouti il se dit ça peut plus durer
nous les yeménites on est trop mou on a
des chefs religieux qui produisent des
des des écrits et des écrits théologiqu
mais qui ne disent rien de ce qui se
passe au Moyen-Orient qui ne condamnent
rien de ce qui se passe euh vis-à-vis de
de des États-Unis et de cette ingérance
occidentale au Moyen-Orient il est temps
que euh de réveiller un peu ce pays et
donc il commence à faire avec quelques
petits euh partisans un petit groupe
commence à euh investir des mosquées des
lieux publics où il fait des des
discours des panflets où il décrit la
main mise des Américains mais aussi
d'Israël et euh et des Juifs alors il
est clair antisémite dans tous ces
discours le mot juif revient tout le
temps le juif il est malin le juif il
contrôle le monde le juif il est
derrière toutes les toutes les misères
du monde en tout cas de toutes les
misères des des Arabes donc il faut
mettre fin à la présence israélienne et
américaine au Moyen-Orient et son le
discours enfin le slogan des outil né à
ce moment-là c'est amult America amult
Israël voilà et qui veut dire qui veut
dire à mort l'Amérique à mort les
Israéliens et donc à ce
moment-là il sont il prend en notoriété
petit à petit c'estes prêche sont repris
carrément par des imams à Sana dans la
capitale où pareil les États-Unis sont
sont pointés du doigt et l'ambassadeur
américain de l'époque qui est en poste à
Sana va voir le président yeménite et
lui dit mec ça va pas du tout
là il lui dit un peu comme ça avec des
une formule plus atique mais en peu ou
prou il lui dit mec ça va pas du tout
nous on vous file des millions d'Ur de
dollars pour en armement en tune pour
vous battre contre Al-Qaïda hein pour
lutter contre le terrorisme et cet
argent là vous en êtes bien content mais
par contre vous faites rien quand il y a
un petit trublillon qui arrête pas de
nous insulter et en plus c'est un effet
boule de neige sur notre réputation au
Yémen donc ali Abdallah salé qui est le
président de l'époque se dit [__] cet
argent là moi j'en ai besoin pas
forcément toujours pour lutter contre le
terrorisme pour hop mettre aussi un peu
dans sa caisse personnelle donc
qu'est-ce qu'il va faire au lieu d'aller
dialoguer avec Hussein badreddin alouti
et bien il envoie les militaires la
police et il y a une répression tout
asimute une répression sanglante et
sévère alors que husin badrialouti était
plutôt d'accord pour dialoguer et puis
pour mettre fin à ces discours là et
pour respecter la la la souveraineté
d'Ali Abdal salé et donc cette
répression s'étend plus seulement aux
partisans de husin badreddin alouti mais
au zaidit au zaidit c'est une branche de
l'Islam
chit qui est qui se trouve au nord du
pays et qui est la branche religieuse de
Hussein badridin alouti et donc il y a
beaucoup de de zaidit qui sont pas du
tout d'accord avec les discours de
Hussein mais qui s'identif F à cette
répression et qui se disent moi pour mes
frères bah je vais rejoindre Hussein
badreddin et puis je vais prendre les
armes et donc d'une petite
poche dont les leaders ont été
emprisonnés et ben on se retrouve avec
une insurrection et cette insurrection
début des années 2000 jusqu'à 2009 il y
a eu plusieurs guerres avec des moments
de paix des moments de reprise de guerre
dans le nord du pays et au Yemen on en
parlait pas c'était ça se passe dans le
Nord il y a des combats c'est un peu
dangereux il y a tant de de de mecs qui
meurent de soldats qui meurent il y a
euh tel chef qui a été arrêté et cetera
mais on en parlait pas beaucoup c'était
un peu mis sous le tapis cette guerre là
et Hussein Badreddine alouti lui en 2004
il se fait il se fait tuer par l'armée
yeménite et à ce moment-là l'armée
yéménite se dit bon on a terminé la
guerre mais en fait pas du tout et en
l'honneur de leur chef les rebelles ont
pris euh le nom de outil donc ils sont
de de leur chef et donc ils sont devenus
les outils et voilà et donc c'est comme
ça que jusqu'en 2011 jusqu'au printemps
arabe il y a eu tout toutes ces
guerres-là le printemps arabe arrive les
les les jeunes sortent dans la rue ils
réclament la tête du président ils en
peuvent plus euh c'est fini on veut plus
la corruption euh ali Abdallah salé il
est au pouvoir depuis 30 ans faut que ça
cesse nous aussi on veut euh avoir des
postes à responsabilité euh euh on veut
que l'économie soit meilleure on veut
plus de liberté bon ça se passe partout
au Moyen-Orient et Ali Abdallah s il
perd le pouvoir il perd le pouvoir à ce
moment-là parce que les pays autour les
pays du Golf les grandes monarchies se
disent à nous on veut pas que ça fasse
boule de neige donc on va intervenir et
on va demander à Salé on va lui mettre
la pression à Ali Abd salé pour qu'il
dégage et pour qu'il ait un nouveau
président alors attention pas beaucoup
plus progressiste quelqu'un qui est dans
l'univers voilà donc ça sera monsouradi
qui va prendre le pouvoir de 2012 à 2014
et là ça va être une catastrophe le pays
va être sans dessus dessous l'armée va
être
divisée mansouradi va carrément donner
certaines villes aux Frères musulmans et
puis il va faire un truc qui va
déclencher totalement le coup d'état des
outils
et le FMI lui demande de serrer la vis
le FMI demande à Adi tu dois tu dois
supprimer les subventions sur le pétrole
et les subventions sur le pétrole c'est
90 % de la nourriture est importée au
Yémen et donc 90 % c'est inflation des
prix c'est crise économique c'est déjà
que le pays les gens étaient très
pauvres le yéen était le pays le plus
pauvre du Moyen-Orient enfin du du monde
arabe carrément et bien là ça a mis dans
la panade beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
familles donc les outils se sont dit
déjà ils étaient déjà ils étaient
descendus de leur montagne ils étaient
allés dans la capitale et ils avaient
fait des des rencontres avec des jeunes
en disant voilà nous on est un mouvement
progressiste ils avaient des discours
très populistes évidemment tout le côté
secteur il l'avait mis de côté il avait
caché donc ils étaient connus en fait de
la population un peu plus qu'avant et
donc là ils se saisissent de de Saada
quelques années auparavant en 2014 il
avaiit déjà pris le gouvernerat et là
ils descendent et ils descendent armé
jusqu'au D et ils sont aidés par une
partie de l'armée nationale yeménite qui
elle est fidèle à qui à Ali Abdal sal
l'ancien président qui avait été mis sur
la touche et qui lui s'est allié avec
ses pires ennemis pour en fait retrouver
le pouvoir et donc là ils font le coup
d'État le l'État yeménite est aux abois
les ministres s'échappent c'est sauf qu'
peu tout le monde se barre ils
descendent tous à Aden et là la
progression des outils elle est elle est
phénoménale du Nord un petit gouvernerat
ils prennent la capitale ils descendent
jusqu'au sud à Aden qui est la la
deuxème la deuxème ville yeménite la
plus importante et stratégique et
stratégique sur le DT de Babel mandem et
là il y a une guerre qui est monstrueuse
à Aden qui est sordine moi j'ai discuté
avec des soldats des résistants parce
que c'était pas des soldats de formation
c'était des des des yemménites qui
voulaient pas être sous la coupelle des
outil vivre sur la coupelle des outil et
qui me raconte qu'en fait c'était des
guerres c'était une guerre contre des
enfants les outil employent
essentiellement des enfants des jeunes
des des mineurs des gosses qui
conduisaient le le le le pickup avec les
soldats derrière c'éta des enfants avec
des kalashnikov les snipers c'était des
gosses et à chaque fois qu'il devait se
battre dans la rue les combats de rue
c'était contre des enfants il voyaient
pas d'adultte les mecs donc c'est dire à
quel point ces rebelles sont dangereux
et à quel point ces rebelles sont prêts
à tout pour récupérer tout le Yemen et
c'est là qu'en 2015 la la résistance
c'était devenu bah des des civils
c'était Al-Qaïda c'était daesh c'était
un espèce de bogi bouga de de de
yeménite qui voulait se battre pour
empêcher que les outils récupèent tout
le pays parce que si Aden tombait tout
le reste
tombait et donc la résistance faiblit en
2015 le le président yeménite appelle au
secours les Émirats arabunis et l'Arabie
Saoudite en disant faut que vous
interveniez les gars parce que moi je
suis foutu on est foutu je peux je peux
vous mettre une parenthèse ouais qui
finance qui arme les outils alors
euh justement quand l'Arabie Saoudite et
les Émirats entrent en jeu c'est là où
les outils euh
ont accéléré leur relations et accru
leur relation avec l'Iran l'Iran étant
un pays cheit les outil étant zaidit une
branche du chisme les outils sont dit
l'Iran Teran s'est dit bah on va armer
les outils puisque ça va embêter notre
rival saoudien puisqueen plus les outils
sont à la la frontière des Saoudiens
donc tant mieux bingo et les Saoudiens
sont dit nous on va intervenir au Yémen
pour mettre fin à cette rébellion qui
potentiellement pourra nous n nous
causer des problèmes parce que proche de
l'Iran et surtout le Yémen on a toujours
voulu avoir la main dessus donc on va
intervenir mais pas pour des causes
humanitaires et pour sauver le peuple
yéménite on va intervenir
pour choper le Yémen et le contrôler ça
c'est une vue de l'esprit c'est ce qui
dit par des grands
géostratèges c'est c'est je suis obligé
de vous demander bien sûr bien sûr alors
il y a l'Arabie Saoudite qui a cette
pensée là et il y a les éirats aussi
mais les Émirats encore pire et et je
vais vous je vais raconter pourquoi
comment comment ça s'est passé donc les
avions saoudiens arrivent ils bombardent
les outils les outils sont obligés de
sortir d'Aden c'est une victoire les
outils sont repoussés un tout petit peu
plus au nord mais ils ont quand même
gardé 30 % du
territoire yeménite voilà qui contrôle
qui
administrent que fait l'Arabie Saoudite
et les Émirats Arab unis à ce momentlà
qu'est-ce qu'ils font bah ils vont en
fait former des milices et des milices
et des milices et des milices des
yeménites qui n'ont pas d'argent des
jeunes qui n'ont pas de boulot bah il
leur file de l'argent un salaire tous
les mois une kalalashnikov il est forme
et ces jeunesl obéissent à un chef
militaire alors il y a un peu de tout
hein il y a des chefs militaires
salafistes il y a des chefs militaires
qui sont frères musulmans euh il y a des
chefs militaires qui sont
indépendantistes mais qui sont
indépendantiste du Sud Yémen mais qui
sont rattachés directement à Abu Dhabi
aux Émirats euh il y a des G qui n'ont
aucune étiquette c'est juste des
mercenaires donc il y a un peu de tout
là-dedans et surtout c'est ces chefs de
guerre sont des chefs de guerre qui sont
révélés pas par leur stratégie militaire
mais seulement parce que à un moment
donné ils avaient le leadership sur
d'autres d'autres d'autres groupes et
que ils sont révélés dans la guerre et
quand on se révèle dans la guerre on
c'est jamais très bon donc ils ont
soutenu en plus de l'armée nationale
yéménite tout un tas de milices qui en
fait ont saisi des portions
très grande parfois du territoire
yeménite dans le sud en tout cas et
c'est et ces milices ont fait leur loi
et comme ses chefs obéissaient soit à
Riad soit Abu Dhabi et bien il y a une
partie une grande partie du territoire
qui s'est retrouvé sous le contrôle des
saouiens des
éemmiratis de fait alors non pas
charia parce que c'est pas ils ont si
vous voulez le le le le le le c'est plus
un contrôle stratégique du territoire
par exemple les Émirats arabuni ce
qu'ils ont fait c'est que ils voulaient
absolument dégager euh un parti
politique yeménite frèr musulmans donc
les Frères musulmans sont les rivaux de
fitete des Émirats arabes unis euh ça
dans beaucoup de pays et donc euh les
Émirats Arab Unis euh quand ils sont
arrivés en 2015 à Aden ils ont contacté
euh des mercenaires américains des
mercenaires français d'ancien
légionnaire ils ont formé une une équipe
notamment euh formée par l'ex de Karine
le mararchand
c'est sourcé ça ah ça c'est sourcé ouais
ça c'est c'est une enquête de buzfeed
c'est une enquête que moi j'ai mené
aussi sur place c'est une enquête qui
est sortie dans la BBC et et l'ex de
Karine l marchand euh forme un pôle de
elle n pour rien elle n'y est pour rien
là-dedans elle y est pour rien ça c'est
vrai et et et donc c'est ce pôle là euh
si vous voulez forme une équipe de
tueurs euh censé éliminer des cibles des
cibles yeménites que qui sont dicté par
les Émirats arabes unis et ces cibles-là
euh sont des des cibles sont des des
personnalités politiques fréristes
Frères musulmans moi j'ai discuté avec
un journaliste yeménite qui avait fui le
Nord il était à Aden dans la zone du
cratère et il était hébergé par le chef
local de la branche des Frères musulmans
la branche politique alisla il
m'explique un soir ils sont là-haut en
train de mcher du 4exlique en anglais ou
en français euh en arabe donc il
m'exlique par couramment arabe alors pas
couramment mais et je j'arrive à me
débrouiller donc il m'explique il me dit
voilà on est en train de de Hazem l4at
donc on est en train de de mâcher du CAT
et puis ils entendent des bruits des des
bruits de tir de kalashnikov et en fait
ces bruits se rapprochent et c'est et
ces tirs carrément
flingue les les murs les fenêtres donc
ils se mettent à couvert puis ils
entendent un grosse détonation de bombe
qui explose et qui souffle tout le bas
de l'immeuble et heureusement eux ils
étaient en haut et euh les tiers
finissent par s'estomper et personne
n'est blessé miracle et en fait c'était
les mercenaires français et américain
qui était venu supprimer et assassiner
tout le monde dans le bureau àisla et en
fait le la tentative d'assassinat a
échoué et ce mec-l a survécu enfin tout
le monde a survécu et si euh ils doivent
leur salut au au pauvres garde d'une
banque de la rue qui qui les a vu
arriver avec des kalashnikov qui leur a
tiré dessus et ils se sont échappés et
les ils étaient les mecs étaient arrivés
sont enfui sont enfu ouais et et les
mecs étaient arrivés avec des des
véhicules émiratis
oui mais ça c'est un bruit de couloir
d'un mec qui t'a raconté que c'est un
bruit de couloir ça c'est ça ça c'est un
ça déjà bon moi c'est une enquête que
j'ai réalisé ça a été corroboré
auparavant parce que c'est c'est le le
le scoop de buossfeed et c'est sorti
récemment dans la BBC là il retrac tout
les et et même ils sont allés chercher
d'anciens mercenaires américains
qui explique c'est c'estes c'estes
d'avoir été engagé par les Émirats Arab
unis au Yémen pour supprimer des
yeménites qui déranger le le le le le le
la volonté des émirats de de de saisir
des pans entiers du territoire et des
pans
stratégiques et d'ailleurs moi si j'ai
été arrêté et expulsé de sookotra c'est
par rapport à ça parce que moi je
m'étais intéressé aussi à cette à ce jou
émirati et je je sais que moi mon
arrestation elle est d c'était une
volonté des émirats mon arrestation à
sokotra c'est triangulé ou c'est juste
c'est pas triangulé c'est pendant mes
interrogatoires avec la police à la fin
la police yéménite euh les mecs ont fini
par me dire c'est pas nous qui voulons
t'arrêter c'est c'est de c'est venu de
plus haut depuis la coalition la
coalition qui gère ce contrat c'est les
Mirat là là là en ce moment ça ça tire
sur des bateaux ça arrache des câbles
internet ouais alors pourquoi tu m'as
demandé pourquoi c'est vrai que j'ai
discuté un peu qui sont les outils en
fait les outils euh ils ont euh une
volonté c'est de d'avoir la
reconnaissance après leur coup d'État de
l'État outil du Nord l'état yemménite
outil du Nord ils veulent être reconnus
internationalement ils l'ont ils ont la
reconnaissance de personne pour
l'instant eux ce qu'ils veulent c'est
l'indépendance et ils veulent terminer
finir euh mettre le coup de grâce au
gouvernement après avoir chopé euh les
territoires les plus peuplés euh du
Yémen et notamment la capitale Sana et
donc en tirant des des des missiles sur
les bateaux qui sont liés à Israël
soi-disant euh pour soutenir la cause
Gazaoui chose que je ne doute pas
puceque les outils dans leur dans leur
propagande c'est toujours on soutient
les palestinien euh à mort Israël à mort
les Juifs et cetera donc dans leur
propagande il tiennent la route c'estàd
que en visant des des bateaux israéliens
c'est c'est c'est leur identité c'est
leur ADN mais tout ça est stratégique
parce que la cause palestinienne ils ont
les chefs les cadres ils en on rien à
faire ce qu'ils veulent eux c'est
tellement emmerder la la communauté
internationale déstabiliser l'économie
mondiale pour obtenir de facto une
reconnaissance des États-Unis de
l'Arabie Saoudite son voisin et et de
toutes les les les puissances
internationales pour forcer en fait les
les la la la la communauté
internationale à se mettre à sa table
avec les Ron derrière quand même avec
les rang derrière ouais mais attention
les outils ne sont pas inféodé à Teran
moi je pense que Teran parfois passe des
coups de fil chez les outils et ils ont
du mal à les canaliser et les les outils
suivent leur propre agenda moi je je
vois pas les outils comme étant le
hzbollah il y a libanais comme étant les
milices irakiennes étant des personnes
qui obéissent à PE près euh au mot là
moi je je suis persuadé que les outils
sont relativement incontrôlable qui
suivent l'agenda des Iraniens l'agenda
stratégique puisque les les deux sont
liés mais que il y a pas de si vous
voulez de de de rapport de de de de
subordination bon ça c'est éclusé on va
passer à autre chose alors durant tes on
se tu toi ouis durant ton petit voyage
là là-bas de
touriste raconte-moi un petit peu ce que
tu as pu voir de d'intéressant ouais tu
veux parler de de mon enquête sur total
de d' de Total oui ou même d'autres tu
es sûr que c'est total d'ailleurs ah oui
oui c'est total ou tu es sûr et certain
c'est pas un prestataire qui totalement
non je suis totalement sûr c'est total
100 % c'est pas une une branche une de
total c'est total AP yemn 100 % total
voilà meameya meameya alors raconte un
peu déjà comment tu t'es intéressé à ce
sujetl qu'est-ce que c'est que ce
sujet-là qu'est-ce que tu as pu voir sur
place quel quelles sont les les
répercussions sur les populations quels
ont été tes contacts avec Total ouais
quel retour alors nous on a essayé de
les avoir au téléphone on a eu
simplement un retour qu'on allait nous
rappeler après l'heure du déjeuner ça
doit faire depuis le 27 février qu'on
attend un retour et et juste avant qu'on
rentre en direct on a essayé de les
appeler et et on a toujours pas de
retour donc euh donne pas je sais pas je
suis peut-être radioactif mais non il
souhaite pas en tout cas avoir un face à
faceace avec moi c'est dommage parce que
moi j'ai pas de de de Hard feeling de de
mauvais sentiments contre eux j'ai rien
contre Total moi je j'ai j'ai fait mon
travail de journaliste donc j'ai dénoncé
des faits et donc tu as rendu compte
j'ai rendu compte puisque les faits
existaient et donc je les ai prouvé VI
des documents des sources des des
témoignageson attaqué ou pas jamais
jamais jamais attaqué enif
passion d'ailleurs sur les réseaux
sociaux jamais non plus ils m'ont jamais
essayé de m'intimider j'ai jamais reçu
de message désagréable de leur part ça a
toujours été très professionnel j'étais
en contact avec leur service
communication j'avais mes questions très
précises ils avaient leurs répones qui
étaient imprécis mais ça c'est c'est
c'est c'est leur fait hein donc il y a
jamais eu de si vous voulez quand on
quand on s'attaque à un tel mastodonte
on peut penser qu'on va recevoir des
pressions qu' va avoir des choses un peu
bizarres mais jusque- là non jusque-
là voilà alors comment moi je me suis
intéressé à à Total tu t'es alors depuis
le départ depuis le départ donc tu étais
à Paris c'est un hasard tu t'es levé le
matin tu as dit tiens non j'étais pas
Paris alors je je vais passer pour le le
reporter arrogant insupportable mais
j'étais en fin de reportage à Bagdad et
et j'aime beaucoup le soir me lire des
rapports en anglais du Sana Center for
strategy strategy study c'est un un
finank yeménite extrêmement brillant
écrit par des Américains des
Anglais des des yéénites et vraiment
super et et je tombe sur un vieux
rapport qui date de plusieurs années
assez long qui parle sans nommer
d'entreprise mais dans des termes précis
qu'il y a des
pollutions causées par des entreprises
pétrolières étrangères dans une partie
de du Yémen donc partie Est est ça
s'appelle adramaout la dramaout c'est le
plus grand gouvernerat c'est là où il y
a les plus grandes Naves fréatiques
d'eau de la péninsule arabique donc les
yaménites boivent moi quand j'étais au
Yémen je buvais de l'eau en bouteille de
la dramaout donc tout le monde boit
l'eau de la dramaout et et et cette
région là est pauvre et elle est assez
ENF sont des gens qui la plupart des
gens sont soit des des grands
commerçants soit ce sont des petits
agriculteurs d'ailleurs la famille Ben
Laden vient de la dramaout euh et donc
je tombe sur ce rapport je le lis bon je
me dis il y a peut-être un sujet à faire
la si un jour je vais au Yémen parce que
j'étais encore jamais là au Yémen à
l'époque si un jour je vais au Yémen je
feris bien ce sujet là je cherche pas le
scoop je me dis pas que ça va être une
entreprise française comme Total je me
dis si c'est canadien Nexen si c'est une
autre compagnie étrangère ça fera un
sujet parce que il y a des populations
qui souffrent de cancer c'était écrit
dans le rapport il y a des pollutions
qui sont terribles et qui qui ont
contaminé contaminé des eaux potables
enfin voilà je me dis euh on va aller
voir sur place on va aller voir sur
place je pars au Yemen en 2021 plusieurs
fois visa touristique non non toujours
visa visa journaliste euh je m intéresse
pas il y a d'autres sujets il y a la
guerre je mets ce sujet dans un carton
je me dis j'ai pas le temps je le ferai
plus tard et la dernière fois que j'y
vais donc sur le territoire euh 2022 je
me dis là ce sujet je le ferai et je
vais le faire et on va essayer finance
moi-même tout ça c'est mon argent c'est
c'est mes économies c'est euh quand je
partais en tant que pigiste
j'investissais dans mes reportages avec
mes fonds propres il y a personne qui me
qui me donnait de l'argent et je me
débrouillais comme ça et donc j'y vais
j'y vais et
euh et à ce moment-là j'avais pour
contact seulement un le numéro d'un d'un
d'un d'ingénieur en agronomie yeménite
il se trouvait que il y avait son nom
dans le rapport en anglais là et j'ai
trouvé son mail je lui avais écré un
mail il m'avait répondu 3 ans auparavant
avec son numéro de téléphone on échange
un peu et il me dit écoute moi je suis
pas au Yemen mais par contte je vais te
filer le numéro de de plusieurs avocats
yeménites ils pourront te parler de
l'affaire il y a pas total il y a rien
qui remonte hein donc je vais sur place
je prends un rendez-vous avec les les
les les avocats on se rend compre dans
ma chambre d'hôtel on se pose sur les
les petits tapis là les petits coussins
il y a du CAT on mche du 4at on parle un
peu de tout et de rien et puis après on
commence à évoquer le sujet et là paf il
me parle de Total et a le mot total qui
vient tout de suite dans la conversation
mais ouais mais la plus grosse
entreprise pétrolière qui a fait les
plus graves pollutions c'est
total et puis il me balance des vérités
alors des choses en détail euh et cetera
euh qui me trouve mais je me non non non
au départ je trouve ça hallucinant au
départ je me dis ça peut pas c'est trop
gros quoi ça peut pas être vrai c'est
trop gros c'est euh c'est énorme je me
fais manipuler ils en
rajoutent je doute parce que moi je suis
pas là pour euh euh seulement via des
allégations sortir une enquête moi je je
je veux des faits je veux des documents
des trucs et ils me disent mais tu sais
nous on a été les les représentants de
enfin les avocats de de victimes de
pollution totale et on a
euh apporté une plainte on a porté
plainte enfin nos clients ont porté
plainte contre au total au tribunaux de
seyun la ville principale en 2015 je dis
[__] je connaissais pas l'existence de
cette plainte donc euh va falloir me
donner des documents
euh pour me montrer un peu ce qui s'est
passé et ils étaient très précis dans
les chiffres dans et et ce qu' me
racontait quel type de chiffre on en
parlera après mais ce qu'il me racontait
euh disait enfin était exactement ce que
j'avais lu dans les rapports euh dans le
rapport précédent euh vis-à-vis des
types de pollution et donc en fait là je
je me disais il y a il y a y a y a il y
a un rapport qui est très sérieux et ces
avocats me disent la même chose je me
dis il y a forcément quelque chose alors
on discute pendant 2 3 heur il y a la
boule de 4 qui me fait devenir
totalement voilà concentré déterminé et
et j'ai qu'une envie je leur dis c'est
bah il faut que j'aille dans les zones
polluées faut que j'aille dans faut que
j'aille voir de mes propres yeux la
drogue c'est dangereux non mais ça m'a
donné de la détermination et du courage
et et à ce
moment-là je je il est question d'aller
voir ces région là sur le bloc 10 le
bloc 10 c'était le le nom du bloc opéré
par Total concession c'est une
concession exactement concession et ce
bloc 10 il se trouve à 70 km au sud de
de la ville et la drama c'est quand même
l'ancien fief d'Al-Qaïda au Yémen et
même si Al-Qaïda à l'époque n'est plus
si fort que que quelques années
auparavant il y a encore des cellules
dormantes qui sont partout c'est pas moi
qui le dis c'est mon guide qui n'est pas
un fixeur qui est juste un type avec sa
camionnette et qui me fait confiance et
qui me qui me qui me véhicule il me dit
il y a les hommes en noir là-bas et je
parle aux avocats ils me disent
effectivement pour toi ça va être un peu
dangereux si tu vas là-bas je dis ben
écoutez les gars moi si je peux pas
aller là-bas il y a pas d'enquête je
sors rien je fais rien il y a pas de
témoignage je vois pas de mes mes
propres yeux les pollution je peux pas
et ils me disent mais attends il y a
peut-être un chef de tribu qui pourrait
t'emmener t'accueillir et lui il est
actif sur les
pollutions il crée des Crowd funding tu
vois des des espèces de de de
financement participatif pour soigner
des gens qui ont des cancers et cetera
des des des des agriculteurs qui ont
perdu leur terre où il y a de temps en
temps du pétrole qui ressort de leur
puit donc ce mec là il est actif et il
est de confiance je dis de confiance euh
bon tu sais que ta mère va plus dormir
là je lu dis de confiance mais il faut
que je vérifie laisse-moi vérifier
auprès de mon mon guide et mon guide il
est un peu roublard il est il a des bons
contacts donc il passe de trois coups de
fil alors le Cher Razi le Cher Razi pas
non cher Razi il est pas de confiance gu
il me dit c'est du 5050 là les avocats
il disent que le gars il si tu le
contactes et si tu le si tu prépares un
truc euh il va pas te vendre moi j'ai
d'autres échos qui me dit que ce typel
il il est pas de confiance donc à ce
moment-là je me dis j'ai j'ai je suis
avec un photographe italien qui est avec
moi et on se regarde et on se dit euh
qu'est-ce qu'on fait bon bah le jeu en
Val aller la chandelle c'est c'est pas
le jeu c'est pas une question
d'adrénaline de mais c'est la révélation
et c'est l'utilité publique de la
révélation qui moi me me fait dire que
qu'il faut qu'on le fasse donc on part
quelques jours plus tard on prend un van
on avait en fait deux
miliciens deux policiers qui nous
suivaiit qui nous escortait parce que
c'est c'était le cas en fait avant notre
arrivée il y avait des humanitaires
d'msf qui avait été enlevé
kidnappé et qui et sur la même route en
fait hein euh et donc par des un faux
checkpoint des faux militaires et
c'était al-qaïa qui les avait enlevés et
donc depuis dès lors dès qu'un étranger
arrivé dans cette région là on leur F on
leur fournissait une escorte une escorte
c'était de flics qui étaient plus plus
petit que moi je suis m 68 ils sont pas
très très grands tu vois depuis
l'invention de la poudre il y a plus
d'homme fort ouais mais bon ça ça dissuè
pas non plus ils étaient dans un dans un
petit van banalisé derrière nous je suis
sûr que sil y avait une une une
tentative de kidnapper ping de al-qaïa
ils auraient pas bougé mais je comprends
moi je je leur en veux pas bref on part
avec la fine équipe on descend le sud de
la dramaout alors la dramaout c'est des
canyons des grands canyons c'est une
série de canyons et il y a des et les
gens habitent dans les vallées et les
routes sont dans les vallées et les
cultures sont dans les vallées et donc
on fait de la route et plus le le le le
chemin passe les paysages défilent moins
en moins de de verdure il y a plus en
plus de terre grisees dés
artiques des arbres morts des espèces de
de de de palmiers avec le le tronc
complètement noir al je t'arrête
peut-être c'est parce que c'est en plein
cagnard qui fait 55°gr qu'ils ont pas vu
la pluie depuis 18 mois et que et que tu
arrives au pire moment alors c'est pas
ça parce que je suis arrivé à un moment
des moussons l'Oût en août il fait très
chaud mais il y a des terribles pluies
qui viennent d'Inde et donc il pleut
énormément et euh et la tu as vu la
pluie qui vient d'Inde aussi c'est ouais
ben quand c'est la pluie elle vient
d'Inde elle est tellement forte qu'elle
coupe les routes parce que tu as des tu
as des tu as des des cru qui sont
énormes et d'ailleurs il avait plus le
le soir même on était arrivé donc on
était pas sûr de pouvoir aller dans ces
zones parce que il y avait des des ouais
des des rivières qui passaient sur les
sur les routes et on pouvait pas passer
donc il y avait cette difficulté en plus
donc finalement on a pu passer mais on a
vu des des ruissaus où on passe la
voiture et tu à la moitié de la voiture
qui est sous l'eau he enfin c'est voilà
donc c'est une région où il pleut et
donc c'est pas la la la cause si tu veux
de de de cette terre morte et de cette
végétation morte c'était pas dû à la
sécheresse c'était dû à autre chose bon
nous on se on comprenait un peu pourquoi
mais au f à mesure qu'on est arrivé dans
le
wadissa
là cette réalité ça nous ça nous est
apparu mais une manière flagrante c'estd
vous avez fait des échantillonnages de
sol vous avez regardé vous avez foré
vous avez fait anal et ensuite vous avez
compris que pourquoi alors le premier
rendez-vous qu'on fait c'est au centre
médical du du petit district et à ce
moment-là on rencontre le le chef du du
district qui nous raconte que les taux
de cancer ont explosé al il y a total
qui vient de me répondre oui désolé
appelons-nous demain ouais mon pote
c'est trop tard pardon désolé bon c'est
tard que jamais euh donc je discute avec
le le le le chef du district le chef
médicale de la petite petit centre de
soins il me dit que le taux de cancer a
explosé que ils ont depuis 20 ans alors
total est arrivé dans la région en 96 et
est reparti en 2015 il y avait qui avant
eux il y personne donc qui après eux
Petro messil là qui est
l'entreprise nationale qui a repris les
les installations total et
donc on discute et il me dit que il y a
un taux de cancer et de maladie
orpheline il connaissait pas pas qui a
explosé depuis 20
ans que ça c'est quelque chose qui
constate et que quand on est malade d'un
cancer au Yémen on a toutes les chances
de d'être condamné à mort et lui lui il
a des States il a une étude sur du long
terme il travaille avec un dispensaire
il y a des mecs qui on fait une étude
alors
c'est juste bon bah il a vu des gamins
avec un petit peu et puis alors il y a
pendant l'entretien il y a une femme qui
arrive tout en noir gant noir et cetera
et il se trouve que cette femme a fait
du bénévola depuis 15 ans et que elle va
euh chez chaque famille euh où il y a un
malade d'un d'un cancer et souvent les
mal des cancers au Yamen sont en phase
terminale parce qu'il y a pas de de il a
il y a pas de matériel pour détecter il
y a pas de matériel pour faire du
euh de la prévention hein donc quand on
est malade un cancer c'est souvent on
est détect enfin on est détecté en phase
terminale donc si vous voulez
aujourd'hui les statistiques depuis 96 à
2015 avec une prise de conscience des
pollutions potentielles de des
entreprises pétrolières aux alentours
bah on a pas de stade très fiable et on
a pas de recul mais par contre on a des
gens qui nous disent que dans chaque
village dans chaque famille il y a
quelqu'un qui est malade d'un cancer ou
qui est mort d'un cancer il a d'autres
entreprises que des entreprises est-ce
qu' a des fermiers ave des pesticides ou
des choses comm ouais je termine la
cette femme là elle me donne une liste
grande grande liste de gens avec leur
numéro de téléphone leur nom leur prénom
avec mort vivant face terminal mort
vivant et elle me lance elle me donne
une liste juste pour le wadissa qui est
un petit District de la Région et avoir
des tels taux de cancer dans un village
comme ça c'est pas normal c'est qu'il y
a forcément quelque chose derrière mais
c'est pas c'est pas sur cette sur C
témoignage là que je me dis ça y est
j'ai prouvé quelque chose surtout pas
surtout pas je me dis bon il y a quelque
chose
je fais rencontre quelques familles dont
les proches les enfants les sont nés
soit avec des malformation soit des
cancers je me dis là autour de moi je
suis comme dans la colline à des yeux je
sais pas si vous avez vu le le film
d'horreur les enfants nés avec des
naissent avec des malformations
terribles les cancers des visages des
gosses parce que c'est cancer du tumeur
du cerveau lymphome au sang et cetera je
me dis là je suis pas dans une région
normale
enfin alors effectivement il y a une
agriculture s euh dans le dans ce dans
ce district enfin dans la dramaout et
partout au Yemen d'ailleurs hein où on
utilise des pesticides qu'on utilise
plus en Europe depuis très longtemps
mais c'est ça donne ça ne donne
pas cette récurrence de cancer de
maladie orpheline à ce point-là en tout
cas on peut pas l'expliquer comme ça on
peut pas se satisfaire de cette
explication là surtout que c'est une
petite agriculture c'est pas une
agriculture intensive c'est pas des
immenses hectares tu comprends tu
comprends pourquoi je te pose la
question ah non mais tout à fait tout à
fait tout à fait question moi c'est
c'est c'est une question déontologique
on peut pas non plus lier les cas de
cancer forcément à une pollution d'une
entopise pétrolière on en a pas la
preuve formelle de toute façon
déterminer qu'un cancer est lié à telle
ou telle substance ou pesticide qui dont
le le corps a été explosé c'est
impossible ça on peut pas le le le le le
prouver scientifiquement c'est pas
possible mais par contre on peut faire
des des suppositions surtout quand ça
reste une supposition oui non mais ça
c'est à ce moment-là quand j'ai cette
supposition à ce moment-là mais après je
vais avoir une série de documents et de
sources qui vont et de témoignages qui
vont prouver que c'est plus que des
suppositions donc après avoir eu tous
ces témoignages également d'agriculteurs
qui me disent que leurs terres sont
mortes parce que après avoir retiré de
du puit et que ce puit il y avait une
espèce de substance noire qui remontait
et cetera que rien ne poussait plus
depuis 20 ans ou que les récoltes
étaient très mauvaises en tout cas pas
comme avant il y a un faisceau
d'éléments qui fait que il y a quelque
chose qui va pas et les gens sont dans
dans la vallée et au-dessus là dans les
canyons c'est total enfin c'était total
jusqu'en 2015 donc
forcément il faut creuser faut creuser
donc après avoir fait ces ces cette
série d'interview euh sur plusieurs jour
où je peux passer que 20 minutes par par
famille par petit bout de territoire
parce que je dois bouger parce que c'est
une règle sécuritaire pour pas qu'il ait
de de kidnapping qui s'organise si
jamais je suis repéré
ben je je décide de de rentrer en ville
et de me poser et de réfléchir et à ce
moment-là je demande aux avocats bah
donnez-moi tous les documents là parce
que vous m'avez dit que vous aviez des
documents des choses bah de de
montrez-moi euh et alors là j'ai pas de
j'ai pas de documents qui arent et euh
bon je je pars dans une autre région au
Yemen je fais autre chose et je rentre
en France et puis je je relance les
avocats souvent j'ai pas j'ai pas de
réponse puis au final un jour j'ai une
réponse de l'avocat qui me dit ouais
j'ai mon mon mon téléphone je l'avais
filé à à mon fils pour euh pour ses jeux
et puis par miracle je suis tombé sur
ton message et euh et ouais ouais
t'inquiète je vais t'envoyer les
documents et il a fini par me les
envoyer un jour euh une salve de
documents des documents de Total euh des
documents obten comment alors des
documents de Total obtenus par les
victimes qui avaient euh déposé plainte
en 2015 pourquoi comment ils ont obtenu
ces documents-là en fait euh en 2008 il
y a eu donc là je vais rentrer dans les
pollutions émise enfin causé par total
il y en a il y a je dirais il y a deux
volets alors moi moi je vais te demander
analyse de sol analyse de flotte date
quel type d'organisme comment ça a été
fait est-ce qu'il y a eu un 2 TR
échantillons sur combien de laboratoires
différents je je je je vais y venir
alors première première chose euh dans
le rapport que j'avais lu il est ce
rapport
établissait sans preuve mais ce rapport
établissait que total pour traiter ces
eaux de production utiliser des bassins
en fait qu'est-ce que c'est l'eau de
production déjà quand dans n'importe
quelle plateforme pétrolière quand on
fait remonter du pétrole du sol euh et
bien ce pétrole contient de l'eau de
l'eau qui est extrêmement salée qui est
faiblement radioactive et qui contient
tout un tas de de métau lourd
puisqu'elle est associée au pétrole les
entreprises entreprises pétrolières pour
séparer l'eau du pétrole pour que le
pétrole soit exploitable et bien ils
mettent dans ce cette espèce de mélange
un un
cocktail chimique qui s'appelle Bettex
et qui est hautement cancérigène c'est
BR ça vient d'où ça c'est ça c'est dans
tous les rapports enfin n'importe quel
ingénieur pétrolier pourra vous le dire
ça c'est c'est la base le betex donc ce
ce
cocktail chimique je l'ai dit il est
hautement cancérigène donc quand on
sépare l' com on sait comment on le sait
comment on sait il y a eu des des des
études qui ont été réalisées sur bah par
plusieurs scientifiques qui ont été
réalisé sur moi j'avais interview un
scientifique qui était un ingénieur
pétrolier en France et en Australie de
de de d'université et qui sont reconnu
ça ça là j'invente rien sur là-dessus
donc une fois que l'eau est séparée du
pétrole elle contient le Bettex des des
des quantités faibles radioactives des
métaux lourds donc cette eau là elle est
très dangereuse cancérigène elle est
radioactive m tau lourd et on ne peut
pas c'est interdit par les standards
internationaux de la jeter ou de la
stocker quelque part il faut la traiter
il faut une usine pour nettoyer ces eau
et cette usine c'est dans tous les
standards de construction internationaux
de de plateforme pétrolière enfin pas de
plateforme de de de champ pétrolier il
faut une usine pour traiter de ces
taux-là parce que c'est cet eau est
extrêmement dangereuse pour
l'environnement et pour l'humain
qu'est-ce qu' a fait total ça coûtait
trop cher de de construire cette usine
pourquoi ça coûtait trop cher parce que
en fait la spécificité du pétrole de
laadramaout c'est qu'il contient quand
on le Fire monter beaucoup d'eau et plus
les années passent moins il y a de
pétrole dans les dans les les
souterrains et plus en fait on fait
remonter l'eau et donc parfois il
remontait jusqu'à par jour plusieurs
centaines de milliers
de baril d'eau de production de cette
eau toxique donc cette eau là il fallait
la traiter et comment vous savez que
c'était trop cher alors ça c'est une
question que j'ai posé en fait j'ai
retrouvé des politiques
yeménites qui se doutaient qu'il y avait
quelque chose qui n'allait pas dans les
installations de pétrolière donc un
ancien député notamment qui se rend sur
place
et avec une délégation d'autres hommes
politiques des ingénieurs pétroliers
yménites ils visitent les
installations il voit les installations
totales et je vais revenir sur ces
installations de comment il traitit
l'eau et il pose la question à nousbi
qui est à l'époque le le le chef le
responsable de Total Moyen-Orient et il
le confronte et lui disent vos méthodes
là pour traiter cette a de production
c'est criminel c'est très dangereux y a
des traces de ça de ces échanges là non
alors c'est des échanges qui ont été
corroborés que
j'ai retracé plusieurs fois enfin avec
plusieurs personnes qui étaient là ce
jour-là en tout cas lors de cette
confrontation avec C des yeménites et
euh à ce moment-là donc la réponse a été
ça coûte trop cher nous on a vu avec
votre ministère du pétrole on était
d'accord si vous êtes pas content allez
voir avec eux donc ça coûte trop cher de
créer une usine de de traitement de de
ces autres productions alors qu'est-ce
qu'ils ont fait c eau ils l'ont pas
balancé au sol non ils l'ont pas ils ont
pas fait ça comme ça ils ont creuser des
centaines de bassins comme on creuserait
un bassin dans son dans son jardin pour
mettre des nénupares et on mettrait quoi
une bageche plastique pour pas que l'eau
s'infile dans le sol quelle superficie
des bassins parce que si c'est s bassin
de nénuar ah non non non c'est des c'est
des très grands bassins alors je saurais
pas dire combien de de mètres mais c'est
ça se voit sur Google Map ça se voit sur
Google Map et c'est comme ça que j'ai vu
d'ailleurs sur Google Map je suis allé
j'ai retrouvé le le l'adresse GPS des
installations total tac j'ai regardé et
on les les passés on les voit de de du
satellite et ils sont noirs puisquil y a
les baches les baches noires et j'ai
fait analyser toutes ces captures
d'écran de Google Earths un ingénieur
pétrolier français non mais l'ingénieur
pétrolier français il est pas
spécialiste en il travaille à l'Institut
français du pétrole d'accord mais il est
pas spécialiste en traitement de de
d'images satl al non non non non mais
attendez une installation pétrolière vu
d'image satellite c'est pas très
compliqué d'analyser ce que c'est le le
le les bassins de rétention d'eau alors
vous savez ce qu'il me dit quand je lui
montre ces ces ces images euh capturé
par par Google Earth je lui dis pas que
c'est total je lui dis je lui dis voilà
c'est une entreprise pétrolière qui gère
son autre production comme ça qui de
quelle année ça ça c'est de 96 à 2015 à
2015 donc en 2015 vous lui montrez les
captures voilà c'est ça et donc je lu je
lui je lui montre ça en fait c'est pas
en 2015 que j'ai fait les captures
c'était en
2023 pendant mon enquête sauf que tous
les enquêtes sont tous les les bassins
sont encore là n'est plus en gestion
total n'est plus en gestion depuis un
moment mais tous ces bassins sont encore
là il y a rien qui a été retiré et c'est
ces bassins il y en a des centaines et
donc je lui montre ces bassins enfin ces
ces installations il me dit ah ouais
mais ça c'est des bassins de rétention
d'eau de
production cette technique pour se
débarrasser de l'eau de production l'eau
toxique là votre entreprise ça serait
pas une entreprise pétrolière de voyou
qu'on qu'on peut retrouver dans le delta
du Niger ah je dis ah non c'est total il
dit non je peux pas vous croire total
ils peuvent pas faire ça ils peuvent
pas gérer cette prod la première chose
que j'entends quand quand vous dites
c'est total qui gère ça moi je peux pas
vous croire alors donc si vous voulez
pas me croire j'ai choper un document de
Total
euh qui date de 2008 qui établit que euh
c'est un c'est un document écrit par par
trois ingénieurs français de Total
authentifié authentifié et qui écrivent
un rapport en disant on a une technique
un tout petit peu plus euh euh
écologique pour gérer euh cette haau de
production parce que et ils disent dans
le rapport parce que cette technique de
bassin avec des bâche en plastique c'est
interdit et en d'un point de vue
environemental c'est dangereux et c'est
ce qui est écrit dans le rapport et on
voit les photos des bassins de Total et
on voit leur solution proposée par les
ingénieurs de remplacer la bâche en
plastique qui se crève avec les UV avec
l'usure et cetera donc qui crée des
infiltration par un revêtement plus
solide et bleu alors pas bleu non ah
mince non pas bleu mais un revêtement
plus solide et donc j'ai ce document là
aussi qui atteste ça et d'ailleurs quand
j'ai posé la question à Total parce que
je me suis rapproché qui vous avz posé
cette question au service communication
il y a pas de nom en particulier c'est
le service communication qui gère
d'ailleurs eux ils ne connaissent rien
de cette histoire ils envoie ça à des
techniciens qui étaient sur place
peut-être auparavant et c'est eux qui
m'ont envoyé les réponses total ne niit
pas total ne nit pas avoir construit ses
bassins de rétention et pourquoi les
bassins de rétention c'est dangereux
parce queon en a pas parlé donc ces
millions de litre d'eau de baril d'eau
de production qui sont sortis toutes les
semain enaccord avec le ministère de
l'Environnement yéménite du pétrole
yéménite de l'ép qui est pas voilà qui
était qui bon on peut pas dire que on ne
conteste pas la souveraineté d'un
ministère je ne dis rien mais en tout
cas ce ministère là n'était pas très
inquiet de la santé de de ces de ces
concitoyens en tout cas à l'époque donc
pourquoi c'est dangereux ces bassins
pourquoi et j'ai posé la question à
plusieurs ingénieurs pétroliers parce
que moi je suis pas un expert je me suis
formé avant avant ça avec eux euh on
déverse ces eau-l ces eau-l on parie sur
quoi sur le fait qu'elle s'évapore donc
tous les produits chimiques Bettex se
retrouvent dans l'atmosphère sont
soufflés par le vent dans la vallée les
gens respirent ça deuxièmement on l'a
dit les bâes en plastique avec les
rayons soleil finisse par se craquler
donc il y a des infiltrations partout de
cette de ces milliers de bassins ensuite
c'est c'est cette eau- là au fur à
mesure elle sèche elle s'évapore mais
elle a toujours une couche huileuse de
pétrrool avec des particules qui forment
petit à petit des boues et ces boues
concentrées deviennent hautement
radioactifes parce que un tout petit peu
de radioactivité dans l'eau c'est pas
très grave bien que ça reste quand même
dangereux mais au fur et à mesure que on
met de l'eau et qui a ses Bou et ses
particules qui sont radioactives qui
s'accumulent ça ça devient un espèce de
goudron qui est extrêmement radioactif
et en fait moi j'ai chopé alors ça c'est
plus tard via mes contacts des rapports
gouvernementaux yéménites écrits de la
main de de du gouverneur qui sont allés
faire des enquêtes sur place parce que
plusieurs fois il y avait des plaintes à
l'époque des gens de la vallée qui
disaient que après des fortes pluies il
y avait des traces noires dans leur
champ et ce et Cera ils sont all les
confrontter total c'est ce qui est écrit
dans le rapport ils vont voir total et
leur disent voilà là il y a eu sur 20 km
20 km des traînés noires vous pouvez
nous expliquer et total dans le rapport
av vous que et bien ils ont construit
ces bassins de rétention d'eau toxique
dans le sillage de l'évacuation de l'eau
des pluies en haut des canyons sans s'en
rendre compte et que parfois l'eau des
pluies emportait les bassins et ces eau
toxiques sur des centaines de kilomètres
donc si vous voulez cette
pollution elle elle a existé de 96 à
2015 à travers notamment parce qu'il y a
pas eu que ça mais ces bassins et
ensuite elle existe toujours parce que
ces bassins sont toujours là et moi je
les vois depuis googleers ces bassin il
y a toujours cette boue radioactive qui
qui est sèche qui est balayée par le
vent par les pluies et encore
aujourd'hui ces pollutions persistent
est-ce que vous avez demandé à Total
comment il faisait pour évacuer les les
les bouts de rétention est-ce qu'ils ont
saisi le problème est-ce qu'ils ont
essayé de nettoyer est-ce qu'ils ont
essayé de parler au au nouveaux
propriétaires que bon il y avait qu même
des déchets industriels potentiels
qu'est-ce qu'ils vous ont dit chez Total
alors total quand je leur demandais quel
était quelles étaient vos techniques de
de
traitement sur cette zoneel des autres
productions ils ont pas répondu ils ont
pas nié le fait que ils utilisaient des
bassins de de le rétention mais ils ont
pas répondu ils ont pas répondu à
comment il gérait cette eau de
production alors je leur ai demandé vous
aviez des usines pour recycler cette
eau- là pour la traiter non ils ont pas
répondu les bassins ils ont pas répondu
il a peut-être a chose à faire hein non
non non moi ils m'ont répondu à
plusieurs questionsin mais sur ça ils
élutent totalement les bassins ils
savent pertinentment que c'est une
méthode qui est interdite qui est
crapuleuse qui est dangereuse interdit o
mais mais le Yémen c'est le Yémen on va
te dire ouais sauf que moi je poserai la
question si vous avez si vous demain
vous créez un champ pétrolier pour
exploiter du pétrole en Norvège en
France dans un pays européen P
occidental est-ce que vous preniez
prendriez ce genre de mesure non parce
que il y a des standards
environnementaux qui sont là pour
surveiller mais aussi ils savent que il
se feraiit reprendre par la patrouille
là il pariait sur le fait que bon le
gouvernement yéménite on les a dans
notre poche parce que non ça c'est une
c'est une suputation non attendez
attendez attendez le gouvernement
yéénite on l'a dans notre poche parce
que on exploite leur pétrole et redresse
ton micro avant de me dire des bêtises
voilà le gouvernement yeménite on l'a
dans notre poche parce que on exploite
le pétrole et qu'on a des accords
financiers très juteux il y a des il y a
des traces de ça B quand total exploite
le pétrole yeménite il y a une partie
qui va dans les caisses de l'État
yeménite ça c'est c'est c'est une
concession c'est voilà c'est normal
donc euh et puis surtout il paraî sur le
fait que c'est une zone extrêmement
isolée et aucun journaliste n'irait
là-bas c'est une interprétation de votre
part alors non ça c'est pas une
interprétation de motre part c'est de ma
part c'est un témoignage que j'ai eu
d'un ingénieur pétrolier français qui
était sur place donc je je je je
continue vous comprenez pourquoi je me
fais l'avocat du diable évidemment
évidemment c'est normal et moi j'ai
beaucoup douté pendant tout le long de
mon enquête qui a duré plusieurs mois et
jusqu'au dernier moment j'ai douté de
chacune de mes informations donc c'est
normal de de poser ce genre de question
euh donc j'ai réussi à trouver et en on
qui me parlait en on pas en anonymat en
on des des des ingénieurs français qui
travaillaient sur le ce bloc là de Total
qui ont travaillé pendant plusieurs
plusieurs années ça c'est sorti ça c'est
sorti oui qui m'ont témoigné qui m'ont
dit exactement alors ils m'ont confirmé
les bassins et il on dit quelque chose
de plus grave et de enfin je trouve très
préoccupant donc c'est cet ingénieur là
qui est expert en en risque
environnemental et en catastrophe qui
n'est pas en procèsvec total pour qui
n'est pas en procès total qui est un
ancien de qui veut pas régler ses
comptes non non pas du tout qui est un
ancien de Total mais qui m'a raconté de
manière très crue et pourquoi bah ça je
je connais pas ces ses motivations mais
je je ne semblait pas qu'il ait une dent
contre son ancien employeur mais lui me
raconte que à un moment donné les
bassins ça suffisait plus c'est-à-dire
que il fallait tellement creusé il y
avait tellement d'eau de de milliers de
barils qui sortaient par jour que ce
qu'ils en faisaient c'est que il
prenaient d'ancien puit pétrolier donc
très très très très profond qui était
inactif et il foutaiit la flotte dedans
donc les anciens puit pétrolier servait
de stockage pour l'eau de production et
ça se fait ça alors ça c'est une
pratique totalement illégale et
extrêmement dangereuse pourquoi parce
qu'un pu pétrolier il faut vérifier son
son étanchéité entre tous les 5 et 10
ans il y a une seule compagnie qui fait
ça une une compagnie française j'ai
oublié son nom qui fait ça et qui est
expert de ça et ça coûte beaucoup
d'argent et et qui vérifie l'étanchéité
des puits mais si vous le faites pas et
bien vous risquez vous risquer des
fuites et parfois il y a des puits
pétroliers dans cette régionl de la
dramaout qui
descendait soit à côté soit en dessous
des nappes fréatiques donc comment vous
voulez que l'eau qui est bu qui est
puisé dans les puits et qui est bu euh
au Yémen euh ne n'est pas pollué comment
vous voulez éviter ça et quand je lui
pose la question je lui dis à cet
ingénieur mais vous rendez compte que là
euh vous risquez enfin aujourd'hui on
est en 2024 euh vos vos derniers vos
dernières actions c'est en 2015 ça fait
euh 9 ans que ces puits pétroliers ne
sont plus contrôlés en tout cas leur
étanchéité vous savez pertinemment que c
va fuir ah ouais mais c'était comme ça
et il disait et c'est mot pour mot il me
dit on foutait la merde dans ces puits
pétroliers et on rebouchait c'est c'est
c'est c'est c'est quand quelqu'un vous
dit ça en on mais un seul deux deux deux
un deuxième ça fait que deux ouais ça
fait que deux sauf que quand il y a
d'autres ingénieurs yeménites pétrolier
qui me confirme la même chose ça fait
plus que deux il confirme en on en on
aussi sous sous ouais en on aussi il me
raconte exactement la même chose donc et
plus des des
députés des des politiques yeménites qui
sont allé FO qui sont allés plusieurs
fois se
plaindre auprès de de du ministère du
pétrole et qui sont allés constater sur
place les installations qui me racontent
la même chose
ça fait quand même un faisceau de
présomption ça fait un faisceau de
présomption et là je vais TEER quelque
chose dans Marianne on va sortir le coup
de grâce qui sort pas le coup de grâce
la la la cerise sur le gâteau de cette
le coup de grâce des preuves si vous
voulez si si je puis dire le coup de
grâce d'épreuv pas pour achever total du
tout il y a pas de mauvais sentiment
vers total mais coup grâce niveau
journalistique fin fin mars ou début
avril on sait pas encore j'avais
euuvent de la part du numéro 2 du
gouvernement yeménite sultane alarada
qui est au Conseil présidentiel j'étais
allé le voir et j'avais eu accès à lui
et je lui avais dit écoute pour une
manière très honnête juste avant de te
rencontrer j'ai fait une enquête sur
j'ai commencé une enquête sur la
pollution des entreprises pétrolières au
Yémen voilà
et et notamment total qu'est-ce que toi
tu en sais parce que tu as été
gouverneur pendant très longtemps d'une
région olière qui est qui est différente
de la dramaout mais est-ce que tu en
sais quelque chose et lui il me dit ah
mais oui avant la guerre en 2014 on
avait commandé un rapport un rapport
gouvernemental qui faisait plus d'une
centaine de pages et ce rapport
établissait que Total comme d'autres
entreprises pétrolières avaient
grandement manqué à leurs obligations et
avaient causé des des pollutions
criminelles et via ce rapport il était
question qu'on les attaque en justice
puis la guerre est arrivée ce rapport a
été mis dans un on il a été enterré toi
tu l'as eu le rapport en main vous
verrez ben évidemment et ce que je tise
là ça sera dans c'est béton carré
cubique
oui ce rapport j'ai fini par l'avoir
est-ce que tu veux qu'on appelle total
tout de suite non leur propose une
interview tout de suite j'ai pas alors
je dois les approcher pour parler de ce
rapport là et pour parler d'autres
choses encore que j'ai j'ai j'ai pu
obtenir mais ça donc ça sortira dans
dans Marian bientôt j'ai pas terminé sur
les parce que là il y a les bassins il y
et cetera mais aussi un pipeline il y a
eu la fuite d'un pipeline qui a explosé
en
2008 donc un pipeline qui n'était pas
enterré pourquoi il était pas enterré
pour des questions de cût ENF on peut le
supposer parce qu'il y a des mouvement
de terrain c'est ça donc le PIP n'était
pas enterré s'il avait été enterré il
aurait été prémuni d'un sabotage ou d'un
problème technique ou d'une explosion
avec la chaleur et
cetera sous l'océan ça allit il y a
quand même des accid toujours est-il
qu'il n'a pas été enterré et que ce
pipeline a explosé personne n'arrive à
me dire pourquoi alors certains me
disent dans la vallée que c'était
Al-Qaïda ou une tribu qui était pas
contente voilà pour faire pour faire
chier total pour ennuyer pour ennuyer
total pardon total me dit pas que c'est
Al-Qaïda total me dit il y a eu un
problème et il le disent il disent pas
concrètement quel était ce problème et
qu'est-ce qui a causé cette explosion du
pipeline toujours est-il que euh ce
pipeline n'avait pas de capteur de fuite
donc normalement il y a des capteurs de
fuite tous les je sais pas centaines de
mètres il y a un capteur qui dès qu'il y
a une baisse de la de la pression envoie
l'information et donc là il ferme les
valves donc ils ont des valves tous les
centaines de mètres et il ferment les
valves et là il y a plus de pétrole qui
sort donc ils endiguent la fuite il y
avait pas ça il y avait pas ces
technologie là je sais pas si à l'époque
ça n'existait pas je pense qu'en 2008 ça
existait mais encore une fois
certainement et ça c'est une supp
position de ma part mais pour une
question de coup il y avait pas ce
pipeline a fui toute la nuit et il a fui
donc pendant plusieurs heures une petite
fuite une grosse fuite alors un pipeline
de cette taille euh le trou il était
gros le trou était gros et on a j'ai la
photo du trou j'ai la photo du pipeline
qui a explosé j'ai la photo aussi de de
comment ce pétrole s'est éparpillé ça
sont des liquide liquide il était
liquide liquide donc en fait comme on
l'a dit vous savez qu'on est au-dessus
des vallées on est en haut des canyons
le pipeline est en haut du canyon il a
fui toute la nuit il a fui dans la
vallée toute la nuit et surtout il a fui
dans les interstices de montagne très
très compliqué à aller chercher à aller
nettoyer donc dans plein de petits trous
de la montagne il y a des milliers de
barils qui ont fu et je dis milliers pas
centaines pas dizaines parce que j'ai
demandé pareil un ingénieur pétrolier
qui était chargé à l'époque de de
d'endiguer ce problème làà qui me dit
qu'il était en France qu'il enterrit son
beau-père qu'on l'a appelé en pleine
nuit qu'on lui a dit voilà euh il faut
que tu viennes parce que il y a eu une
fuite donc lui il est dépêché sur place
il constate et lui il me dit que oui il
y a des milliers de barils de pétrole
qui ont fui ce soir-là et ces milliers
de barils de pétrole ils ont fui sur une
parcelle agricole et surtout ils se sont
comme j'ai dit éparpillé dans ces petits
trous de montagne voilà infiltré
infiltré voilà moi j'ai les photos parce
que il y a un ancien ingénieur français
qui m'a qui a gardé ses photos qui me
les a envoyé donc on voit que c'est pas
une petite fuite c'est une fuite assez
importante et alors là
c'est dingue mais les les deux
ingénieurs qui étaient chargés de de du
nettoyage et de de gérer cette crise me
raconte toujours on avec leur le leur
nom et leur prénom que ils ont fait ça
pardessus la jambe c'est-à-dire que en
on en on en on oui c'est une faute en on
quelqu'un me dit l'ingénieur me dit en
question c'était une région on
considérait que c'était une région qui
était pas peuplée du tout il y avait
personne on a filé un peu d'argent aux
populations du bas sans protection pour
polir les cailloux parce que Total avait
peur que il me dit ça total avait peur
que des journalistes tombent sur ce truc
mais on n pas fait on n' pas fait des
des des pollutions des sols comme ça le
mériterait et en fait quand il y a une
une une une une une fuite pétrolière je
prends l'exemple dans mon enquête sortie
dans l'OPS j'ai j'ai oublié un peu le le
le le le nom de la région mais il y a
une fuite pétrolière en France pendant
des mois et des mois et des mois ils ont
traité les sols ils ont récupéré des
tonnes et des tonnes de sol qu'ils ont
soit mis dans dans des dans des dans des
contenur de de de de de produits
toxiques dangereux soit qu'ils ont
traité et cetera il y a eu un suivi mais
sur des mois et ils considèrent encore
aujourd'hui après la fuite en France que
cette zone-l n'est plus habitable vous
imaginez au Yémen ce qu'ils ont fait
seulement c'était polir les cailloux
aller avec des pompes des tuyaux pomper
dans les petites mares le pétrole ils
sont pas allés dans les interstices des
montagnes ils ont pris des buloser ils
ont fait des tas de sables pour éviter
que quand il pleut et bien l'eau avec le
pétrole qui ressortirait des interstices
s parpill trop loin mais voyez Ctait
juste des tas de sable avec des B des
coussins absorbants mais c'est c'est du
c'est un c'est un
c'est un pansement sur un cancer c'est
rien du tout ils ont essayé ça a duré un
mois et demi ils ont essayé ils l'ont
fait pour la forme euh mais c'est pas ce
ne sont pas des dépollutions dignes d'un
d'une d'une d'une maraine noire c'est
pas les mêmes règles je vais vous dire
oui mais les mêmes règles ce qui fait
que encore aujourd'hui moi j'ai des
rapports un rapport qui date de 2017
plus les témoignages qui me racontent
vidéo à l'appui qu'il y a encore du
pétrole qui fuit qui sort de ces
montagnes après des des moussons alors
est-ce que ce pétrole ce pétrole il a
été analysé on sait d'où il vient il a
une carte
d'identité qui a fait les analyses
est-ce qu'il y a eu des analyses de
flotte de sol de par qui ou quand
commentoui j'ai un rapport
gouvernemental yénite yeménite qui date
de 2008 donc c'est un rapport qui date
d'avant la l'explosion du pipeline et
qui se f qui qui analyse des sols qui
ont été euh taché de noir après la fuite
d'un bassin qui a été emporté par la
pluie quelques jours auparavant et donc
ce sont des des fonctionnaires
missionnés par le gouverneur qui vont
sur place et qui font des échantillons
des prélèvements de sol et d'eau et sera
fait avec les règles de l'art fait alors
fait avec les règles de l'art puisque
ils ont été transmis à l'université
scientifique de
laadramaout et donc moi j'ai le les
résultats de ce rapport le problème
étant que euh au Yémen on n'a pas les
moyens nécessaires pour pousser les
investigations sur des pollutions aussi
importantes et donc les standards qui
ont été analysés sont des standards sur
le le mercure sur le plomb mais sont ce
ne sont pas des standards qui vont très
très loin dans l'analyse pour prouver
que les sols sont cancérigènes que l'eau
peut-être cancérigène alors il y a des
taux qui sont beaucoup plus importants
et qui vont au-delà parce que moi j'ai
fait analyser les les le rapport à par
un tox un un expert en pollution du CNRS
parce que moi j'y connais rien hein donc
j'ai fait analyser ce rapport et c'est
lui qui me dit que euh les taux euh en
en en en plomb en mercure sont beaucoup
plus importants que ce
que ce qu'établit euh le le les normes
les normes mondiales euh le l'OMS donc
là déjà là-dessus on a une preuve que
c'est une pollution euh qui euh qui peut
potentiellement provoquer des cancers
euh parce que il y a il y a ces normes
enfin il y a ces ces concentrations
anormales dans l'eau et dans la terre si
on si l'université scientifique de la
dramaout avait eu les moyens d'aller
plus loin je pense que les les les les
les les résultats auraient été également
accablants sauf qu'elle en avait pas les
moyens et et
plusieurs si vous voulez euh concitoyens
enfin citoyens yéénites m'ont dit queils
ont essayé de faire ces analyses
également plus tard dans de l'eau dans
des dans des sols pareil qui était qui
était pollué en envoyant ses analyses à
Sana qui était le la seule ville où il y
avait un laboratoire qui pouvait pousser
ces analyses sauf que ces analyses les
résultats n'arrivaient jamais pourquoi
parce que on savait très bien
que le gouvernement yeménite d'Ali
Abdallah salaleeh à l'époque couvrait
les les les les le le total puisqueil y
avait un ce partenariat économique entre
le pouvoir très bien c'est une
suputation c'est une suputation mais qui
n'est qui n'est pas qui n'est pas
totalement naïve cette
supputation pourquoi si vous voulez le
le mystère des du pétrole yeménite a
laissé faire total par rapport à ses
installations sachant très bien ils
était pas au courant ah ils étaient pas
au courant vous pensez que c'était pas
au
courant quand on les appelle ils étaient
pas au courant pas au courant bon c'est
pas si on va sur place maintenant est-ce
que tout est beau tout est propre si
j'appelle des copains yéménite je leur
dis tu vas à tel point tu me ramènes tel
type de sol tel type de terre rien
changé rien a changé rien a changé rien
et Petro messila qui a repris les
installations de Total puisque total
s'est enfui euh s'est enfui est parti
est parti parce qu'il y avait la guerre
parce qu'il y avait des actions
d'Al-Qaïda de plus en plus dans la
région que le gouvernement yeménite
avait changé et que 2015 bah fallait
quitter et ils ont quitté ils ont ils
ont cédé leurs installations en payant
une somme très
importante à péomessila l'entreprise
pétrolière nationale et ils ont ils ont
donné plusieurs millions d'euros moi
j'ai moi j'ai le contrat j'ai le contrat
de de de de cette cessession de
cessation cessation pardon d'activité et
puis le fait de de transmettre leurs
installations sans nettoyer donc ils ont
donné une une grande somme d'argent à à
Petro messila et Petro messila de ce que
Ch d'
yeménit qui sont encore sur place rien
n'a été nettoyé donc les les pollutions
sont encore présentes et et affecte
encore la population
environnante la population environnante
elle en dit quoi elle est désuvrée elle
attend justice elle attend que la fin de
la guerre arrive elle attend des
meilleurs jours ou elle est complètement
désignée alors la population
environnante
elle est désœuvrée elle ne sait pas pas
forcément que c'est à cause des
entreprises pétrolières ou alors en tout
cas pas dans les détails et par que
toutes les entreprises toutes les
marques de pétrole qui sont dans le camp
font la même chose avec les bassins oui
tous toutes à peu près tout enfin moi
j'ai pas la preuve que toutes mais je
sais que Canadian Nexen qui était le le
le bloc voisin numéro 14 faisait la même
chose avec l'ARE production et là eux
c'était carrément ils prenaient des des
robinets à pour arroser la pelouse et il
faisaient comme ça avec l'eaure
production pour la la la l'éliminer
alors c'est peut-être pas carrment dans
le peutêtre pas total peut-être c'est
ceux d'à côté non non mais non c'était
les installations totales là sur
lesquelles j'ai j'ai investigué moi euh
alors les populations environnantes ne
sont pas au courant souvent sont désuvré
elles ne parlent pas
anglais donc elles ont pas accès
toujours à l'information elles elles
sont parfois
illétrées ce sont des populations qui
sont très fragile économiquement quand
on a un cancer s'il y a pas de de de de
cagnotte on meurt
voilà et alors autre chose encore sur
total c'est que moi mon investigation je
la sors en avril dans l'Obs je la fait
traduire avril de cette année Avril
l'année dernière l'année dernière je l'
fait traduire en arabe par un traducteur
certifiéalco pas de lalco mais un
yeménite qui parle bien français je la
fait traduire en
arabe je la publie sur mon blog en accès
libre parce que je considère que c'est
une information qui doit directement
aller au peuple yéménite et pas
forcément en premier lieu au français et
là ton site internet tombe non mon site
internet ne tombe pas mais il y a
beaucoup de trafic alors que personne ne
connait mon blog il y a beaucoup de
trafic et il y a beaucoup de lecturees
et je suis interviewé par des chaînes
yeménites qui m'appellent j'ai des
contacts des des diplomates yeménites
qui m'appellent des politiciens plein de
potes qui ne connaissent potes yeménites
qui ne connaissent rien de mon travail
sur total me disent [__] c'est ton
papier il m'envoie ça sur WhatsApp c'est
le tien et cetera c'est dingue ce que
que tu racontes on savait que tu
travaillais pour la
DGSE il m'appelle voilà donc et et et je
reçois un mail un jour et c'était les
les
cinq paysans yéménites qui avaient porté
plainte en 2015 et qui avaient
mystérieusement retirer leurs plaintes
parce que leur avocat m'avait dit nous
on a représenté ces gens-là on est allé
jusqu'à un certain point il y avait la
plainte qui a été reçue par le juge mais
mystérieusement ces types se sont retiré
et la plainte n'est pas jusqu'au bout
c'est irine brokovic ton histoire et je
me dis mais vous pouvez me donner le
numéro de vos clients ah on a perdu la
trace de client c'est plus où ils sont
et là je reçois un mail écrit dans un
anglais chancelant en disant on est la
tribu aljabri et on est les je suis le
le le le neveu d'un des cinq qui a porté
plainte contre Total on veut parler on
veut vous parler on a des choses à vous
dire bon je je me dis intéressant je
vérifie leur papier d'identité je vois
que c'est bien eux et cetera et là il
m'envoie des documents incroyables et en
fait il m'envoie le contrat qu'ils ont
passé avec Total et Petro messila pour
cesser de réclamer des des compensations
financières et de retirer leurs plaintte
en échange de plus de 200000 dollars et
là je me dis ça aurait pu donner plus
200000 dollars c'est rien 200000 dollars
oui c'est pour traiter un cancer aux
États-Unis c'est de journée c'est ça
c'est pinots effectivement c'est pinots
mais ces gens-l sont pas non plus au
courant des sommes que peut débourser
c'est total ils ont une pression ils me
raconte monumentale de la part mise par
le gouvernement yéménite par Total par
Petro messila par des intermédiaires qui
ne connaissent pas qui viennent quel
type de pression totale ou ou alors
c'est pas des pressions physiques on
leur dit pas vous allez vous faire tuer
on va vous tuer c'est vous vous
n'obtiendrez jamais rien de notre part
euh pas d'argent euh si vous n'acceptez
pas ça trace de ça alors c'est eux qui
me racontent que ces échangesl il y a
TR les trac par contre ce que je sais
c'est que Total et ça j'ai les traces
total leur a versé TR trois fois des
compensations financières de 2008 2009
2010 après l'explosion du pipeline
puisque le le pétrol à coulé sur leur
champ trois compensations à partager
entre 100 paysans de 58000 dollars donc
58000 dollars divis par 100 ça fait
10080 dollars par tête de PIP ce qui
n'est rien et pour une année de récolte
et à l'époque totale pour déterminer
cette ce montant avait envoyé un
ingénieur français euh spécialisé en
agronomie et un anthropologue aussi du
Yémen pour aller en bas parce que
voulaient pas descendre en bas pour
desccendre en bas pour aller voir les
paysans et établir combien ils gagnaient
par an euh à travers via leur culture ce
type-là Frédéric pela que j'ai
interviewé qui m'a envoyé son rapport
qui m'a expliqué qu'il avait été
missionné par Total
établit à l'époque que une une récolte
de de cette de ce petit parcel c'est
58000 dollars et donc en fait total a
suivi le rapport PAF leur a donné 58000
dollars en compensation j'ai le document
de Total qui parle pas de pollution ils
sont très malins les termes employés en
anglais et en arabe dans le dans le dans
le document parl de cause d'effets mais
pas de pollution pas d'accident
n'emploie jamais ce mot-là et je pense
par prudence mais il y a bien les
montants les années et les compensations
qui sont versées à ces agriculteurs qui
sont nommés et la signature et a la
signature de du chef de total de
l'époque le tampon de Total et j'ai même
l'échec les traces d'échec de de de
Total donné à ces paysans donc ces
paysans ont considéré qu'après 3 ans ces
58000 dollars n'étaient vraiment pas
suffisants à se diviser par 100
personnes que leur terre était toujours
aussi peu rentable et qu'ils voulaient
plus de compensation et c'est pour ça
qu'ils ont initié cette procédure
judiciaire et c'est et total vous laiss
s éviter un procès manifestement en
payant ces ces paysans et ça c'est des
révélations que j'ai sorti dans
Marianne l'année dernière voilà donc là
il y a encore un autre volleet qui
arrive j'ai l'impression vol arrive ou
qui a l'air un peu constill oui oui oui
et et donc on voit bien que Total essaie
de nettoyer
d'indemniser pas avec des critères
occidentaux ils vous répondent pas au
téléphone il alors si si si ils ont joué
le jeu c'est-à-dire que moi je leur ai
envoyé plusieurs sales de questions très
précise ils ont eu des réponses qui que
moi alors moi je leurai pas avancé ce
que j'avais évidemment euh j'avais tout
gardé je le je leur disais pas quelle
preuve j'avais et donc il a été très
facile pour moi de de démonter leurs
allégations via les preuves de documents
et les témoignages les photos les les
voilà ça a été ça a été assez simple
j'ai été j'ai eu j'ai eu peur qu'il me
fasse douter et ils auraient pu he me
faire douter en m'amenant des preuves en
menant des rapports des choses ici et là
non ça n'a pas été le cas
l'investigation n'a pas du tout vaciller
après leurs réponses on a publié
évidemment comme on se le on le doit on
doit le faire nos réponses leur répones
dans l'OPS au fur et à mesure de
l'enquête mais voilà ça il y a pas eu de
leurs réponses ne m'ont pas en tout cas
n'ont
pas fait trembler l'enquête et en tout
cas les les
résultats on va prendre quelques
questions internet allons-y euh ah après
les questions internet la déontologie
journalistique tu la vis comment tu
penses toujours contre toi tu essaye de
de toujours être l'avocat du diable tu
essayes toujours de d'être la la la voix
opposée où on essaie de de de
murbupiner ouais toujours il y a
toujours une voix la voix de la raison
la voix de l'éthique et qui qui me dit
non mais là ce qu'on dit c'est c'est un
B bar c'est trop gros il faut le
vérifier c'est pas assez détaillé là ce
que tu as c'est pas assez béton c'est
pas assez sourcé euh ce témoignage là il
est suspect ce type là il a pas une
position très intéressante donc il est
pas très crédible dans le papier donc je
me dis toujours ça et d'ailleurs
jusqu'au dernier jours j'ai douté de de
mon enquête j'ai corroboré corroboré
énormément d'éléments euh les bassins
euh les les les puits pétroliers dans
lesqueles on mettait de l'eau de
production la fuite du pipeline les
cancers et cetera tout ça j'ai bétonné
le plus possible et j'ai essayé d'avoir
le plus d'éléments de témoignage qui qui
croisaient tout ce que j'avais pu
obtenir et ça c'est ça c'est ça c'est
vital et encore plus quand on euh
s'attaque à à total on sait pertinemment
que c'est une grande multinationale
puissante et que ils ont des moyens de
de nous faire douter à travers
des des enfin ça serait pas la première
fois qu'une multinationale emploierait
des des des des documents un peu
détourné des choses et pour nous faire
pour me faire douter ou ou me trouveraai
des témoignages un peu différents enfin
des des des ingénieurs qui me diraient
pas toute la vérité
ça pas été le cas c'estàd que leur
réponse habiculteur les habiculteurs
mais ça n'a pas été le cas et c'était et
si vous faites référence à à
rien ok et ça a pas été le cas et ça a
été un QCM que j'ai envoyé par fichier
Word avec des réponses plus ou moins
développées et je trouve qu'ils étaient
mal préparés c'était mal préparés je
crois pas qu'ils avaient qu'ils avaient
demandé à beaucoup de d'anciens du du
bloc de démentir ce que je sais c'est
qu'ils ont sondé tous les ingénieurs ou
les salariés de du bloc sur de 96 à 2015
parce que les deux témoins que j'ai
interviewé m'ont concédé après qu'ils
avaient été appelés par Total pour
savoir s'ils avaient
parlé et ok bon question internet
craint-il que ces emails SMS appel soi
surveillés par les autorités français
avant de partir en mission
euh je ne représente pas
un danger pour le la France ni pour ses
intérêts pas à ce point-là en tout cas
je ne suis pas mal Auru
euh Malu dans de Matthieu Kassovitz dans
le bureau des légendes donc je je pense
pas représenter je pense pas être à ce
point-là important et à ce point-là
révéler des secrets d'État qui fait que
ça va faire vaciller un ministère un
ministre ou un président non pas à ce
niveau-là donc je ne crois pas être être
mis sur écoute en tout cas pas pas pour
le moment par par l'état français en
tout cas est-ce que tu connais la
procédure pour passer sous les radars
alors la procédure pour passer sous
lesadar sur les radar il y en a
plusieurs mais moi je pars du principe
qu'une une entreprise multinationale
aussi puissante que Total ou un état je
te parle pas de Total je te parle qu tu
vas faire balader multinationale ou une
multinationale puissante ou un étatier
entreprenant un état voilà dictatorial
s'il veut s'il veut savoir ce qu'il y a
dans ton ordinateur dans téléphone peu
importe les petites précautions que tu
vas prendre toi de ton côté il pourra
donc évidemment moi je joue pas avec le
feu je une adresse mail pour ton mail je
com un tails tu as un tails sur ta bécan
hein un tails non ok j'ai j'ai tu
chiffres non non plus tu chiffres pas
non j'ai signal j'ai au lieu d'envoyer
des documents comment tu fais pour
protéger tes sources alors mes sources
c'est simple j'ai un téléphone j'ai
plusieurs téléphones et j'ai un
téléphone où j'ai sign al où je les
appelle comme ça à chaque fois et donc
je peux pas faire plus tu veux qu'on
fasse une petite
formation
mais tout en tout cas en tout
cas si j'ai été espionné
ou au cours de cette enquête par exemple
ou d'autres
euh ça n'a pas permis à des états ou à
des entreprises de
d'arrêter une enquête de la perturber ou
de de dissuader quelqu'un de
témoigner chiffrer c'est quand même pas
mal mais bon des fois ça peut éveiller
les soupçons question internet qu'est-il
alors qu'est-il allé faire au Maroc sans
autorisation pour faire du journalisme
sur place pour interrogation je prends
les questions dans l'ordre ok pourquoi
s'est-il plain d'avoir été expulsé sans
explication le Maroc n'est-il pas un
pays souverain qui a le droit de décider
qui entre sur son sol et qui n'entre pas
voilà à mon avis il doit être marocquain
lui OK ok alors pour répondre à
ça en
septembre
kam donc en septembre dernier j'ai été
j'ai été arrêté et expulsé du Maroc au
bout de de 5 jours de travailoui raconte
un peu ils sont venus te serrer sur un r
son sé à 3h du matin dans mon hôtel à à
Casablanca ils ont toqué à la porte ils
étaient une vingtaine de types masqué et
donc voilà même pas fait room service
même pas ça a été ils ont pas été brutal
ils ont été correct ils m'ont pas
brutalisé mais ça a été très ferme
c'estd tu prends tes affaires on t'amène
à l'aéroport tu passes la nuit au poste
et le premier avion le lendemain tu
rentres et tuas même pas demandé une
petitte club un petit café alors si ils
m'ont offert une petite vioiserie ils
ont pas été ils ont pas été méchant ils
ont ils ont rien saisi de mon matériel
ils m'ont posé aucune question ils
savaient que je j'enquêtais sur les
affaires du roi que j'avais interviewer
des gens qui étaient voilà proche de de
de enfin enfin des gens qui n'étaient
qui étaient peu favorable à la royauté
et au marzen l'état profond donc c'est
en c'est pour ça que j'aiété arrêté et
expulsé du Maroc
moi le Maroc a tout à fait le droit de
de de m'arrêter de de
m'expulser bon c'est juste ça ça dénote
que ce n'est pas un état démocratique où
on peut investiguer chercher en tant que
journaliste sur sur tous les
sujets et je si je ne suis pas je me
suis pas déclaré en tant que journaliste
pour aller au Maroc bah c'est tout
simplement parce que si je vais voir
l'ambassade marocaine je leur dis ben je
veux faire une enquête sur le sur les
affaires économiques du roi vous pensez
bien que je n'auraiis jamais un visa
donc voilà pourquoi je me suis pas
déclaré à ce moment-là moi je sais qu'il
y a aussi énormément de journalistes qui
sont allés dans le cas du tremblement de
terre qui sont pas déclarés et qui sont
passer entre les gouttes qui ne sont pas
fait bizarrement arrêter et expulser du
pays donc voilà mais j'en tiens pas du
tout rigueur au Maroc c'est un un pays
magnifique et il y a j'ai j'ai il y a
des gens très très très sympas là-bas et
qui sont pas tous inféodé à leur roi et
et à ce que à ce que peut raconter cette
dictature parce que le Maroc c'est une
vraie dictature faut le dire il y a des
il y a des journalistes marocains Maradi
risuni qui sont emprisonnés
euh et qui sont emprisonnés parce que
ils enquêtait sur sur les affaires du
roi et de ses proches et on leur a
trouvé des histoires judiciaires
crade et on les a mis en prison comme ça
il y a aussi le Maroc qui mène une
guerre contre le les les saraoui au
Sahara Occidental une guerre sale moi je
reviens là j'étais en Algérie j'étais
dans les camps et j'ai vu des des des
civils qui m'ont raconté qu'il se
faisaient bombarder par les drones les
drones marocains et que les drones
marocains s'en prenaient au à des civils
à des Bédoins qui vivaient dans sur leur
propre territoire donc le le Maroc c'est
pas c'est pas en tout cas je veux dire
la le le le le le le système la royauté
la monarchie n'est pas une démocratie
c'est pour vous c'est pas pour moi c'est
quand on tue des des des civils on
arrête des journalistes on peut pas
s'afficher comme étant une une
démocratie la France qui tire au LBD 40
sur sa population pendant les gilets
jaunes alors que c'est pas démocratique
du tout et moi pendant les gilets jaunes
que c'est une arme guerre c'est une arme
de guerre ça éborgé beaucoup de de gens
qui étaient sortis pour pour la plupart
pour la première fois dans la rue pour
réclamer quoi une plus de dignité plus
de service public une meilleure vie des
des salaires plus décents qu'on les
écoute et et la bourgeoisie la
bourgeoisie au
pouvoir elle a envoyé le le la
répression est-ce que ça ressemble à à
des techniques répressives que tu peux
voir dans des
pays pas folichon en terme ou ça
ressemble à des techniques
contreinurrectionnell du gen parfois
parfois le tire en pleine tête parfois
ça va même plus loin que des techniques
répressives dans ces pays moi je me
souviens j'étais à Oman qui est pas une
une démocratie où la moindre
manifestation est réprimée et les les
les opposants sont arrêtés les Omanis me
disaient en plein crise des gilets
jaunes qu'est-ce qui se passe en France
de voir ces ces ces gens éborniés ces
tirs ces ces gens matraqués ils étaient
choqués ils étaient choqués et pourtant
à Oman c'est la la la les forces c'est
pas des c'est pas des rigolosin donc
donc c'est pas à minimiser ce qui s'est
passé pendant la pendant les gilets
jaunes et moi ça m'a ça m'a beaucoup
touché ça m'a beaucoup atteint parce que
j'étais pigiste à l'époque et j'étais
pas quelqu'un qui gagnait bien sa vie et
je me suis je me suis identifié pourquoi
je je dois donner mon salaire tu es pas
obligé mais tu peux le dire combien Mo
j'ai rien à caché moi je je suis payé
4000 € brut par mois chez Marian donc
net ça fait à peu près 3000 n 3000 et
quel ouais net ouais niche fiscale niche
fiscale c'est-à-dire 7500 € par an alors
ça c'est avec la carte journaliste c'est
ça ouais la carte de presse carte de
presse ouais tu as une carte de presse
oui DEP Marian dessus alors Marian
depuis depuis cette année avant j'étais
pigiste donc j' la patrone elle est
gentille ou elle est pas gentille
Natacha Polonie ouais moi c'est moi je
trouve que c'est une une femme brillante
et intègre al oui intègre brillante et
et nuancée alors alors là on vient de me
montrer dans une source de la voie du
Nord le gouvernement attends arrête de
changer le gouvernement réduit la
distance de tir LBD de 10 m à 3 m les
gendarmes s'inquièent
ouais ouais miaapart aussi ouais le
LBD40 à 3 m alors j'espère qu'ils ont
diminué la poudre parce que sinon ça va
faire des trous moi je suis allé
manifester plusieurs fois des des manif
des gilets jaunes manifester en tant que
manifestant ou en tant que journaliste
manifester en tant que manifestant en
tant que citoyen parce que un
journaliste il a droit de manifester
manifeste pas comment un journaliste qui
va couvrir il ne manifeste pas il couvre
non il couvre mais moi j'étais là en
tant que manifestant parce que j'ai
jamais couvert de manifestations de
mouvements sociaux je considère que je
fais autre chose comme journalistme et
et donc je suis allé manifester en tant
que citoyen et c'est vrai que bah on a
peur de quoi on a peur de perdre un œil
en allant manifester en France c'est
normal
ça chaud question internet celle qui
suit bon bonjour quel souvenir
garde-t-il des hatrick et son accusation
de plagiaat erreur de jeunesse 5 livres
à conseillé sur le Yemen ça après en
dernier
oui alors ça c'est c'est une histoire un
peu un peu c'est bizarre qu'on qu'on
qu'on ressorte ça c'était en 2014 moi
j'ai commencé chez SoFoot donc un média
de un média de foot vous connaissez un
un magazine de foot donc j'étais jeune
journaliste et j'ai j'ai écrit un papier
j'ai coécrit d'ailleurs qu' un autre
journaliste romain du château un papier
sur un club de foot écossais et il se
trouvait que cette idée de sujet était
celle de un journaliste qui s'appelle
romain Molina qui écrit sur le le foot
qui écrivait sur le foot à l'époque et
se trouvait que c'était un club de foot
Hamilton qui cartonnait bien en D1
écossaise à l'époque et on écrit j'écris
le papier après que lui l'ai publié
d'ailleurs je savais pas du tout qu'il
avait publié ce papier là et donc que
Romain Molina m'accuse de l'avoir plagié
donc il est il a appelé plusieurs fois à
la direction de sa fooot s'en est plein
évidemment il y a pas du tout il y a
aucun plagat il y a aucun mot qui
ressemble et vous pensez bien que si moi
j'avais plagié un papier ben j'aurais
pas continué ma carre chez SoFoot mais
j'ai pendant plusieurs années j'ai
continué avec eux et ces accusations de
plagat ont continué ça a pris la la
forme de un espèce de harcèlement donc
moi j'ai porté plainte à l'époque contre
romain Molina mais qui ne vivait pas en
France et je pense que là la justice a
écarté assez vite le le l'histoire parce
que c'était une histoire de bakassab
finalement et c'était une histoire de de
de je pense de de jalousie après je je
sais pas pourquoi romain Molina m'a m'a
m'a m'avait accusé de ça mais en tout
cas cette histoire n'est pas allée plus
loin parce que il a il a suffi de
comparer en fait les deux les deux
articles tout simplement qui sont
disponibles sur Internet euh pour voir
qu'il y avait il y avait pas du tout de
de
plagè alors question qui n'est pas une
question Internet le BTX classé
cancérigène groupe 1 par l'agence
international de recherche sur le cancer
IARC 2020 donc ça a pas l'air d'être
très recommandable dans le café euh
est-ce que votre invité est déjà allé à
Gaza ou la Palestine en général alors
malheureusement non euh je suis je ne
suis jamais en Palestine et jamais à
Gaza et le conflit israëlpalestinien je
m'en suis toujours tenu à
l'écart non pas parce que c'est pas
intéressant et que c'est complexe mais
parce que je considérais qu'il y avait
des journalistes des correspondants qui
travaillaient là-bas depuis très très
longtemps qui avaient une expertise et
que moi j'avais rien à apporter à à ce à
ce à ce conflit-l en tant cas en terme
d'information voilà donc là aujourd'hui
je m'y intéresse parce que c'est dans
l'actualité parce que je travaille dans
un service international et je peux pas
seulement couvrir mes pays le Yémen et
donc je me'y suis beaucoup intéressé euh
je vais rencontrer prochainement des
familles Gazaoui qui ont pu être
exfiltré qui sont en France aujourd'hui
et je pense que c'est très très
important que les médias français
donnent la parole au aux civils Gazaoui
aux Palestiniens et qu'il y ait un une
couverture équilibrée du
conflit question internet Quentin est-il
au courant des nouveaux projets de
raffinerie dans le monde alors de
raffinerie c'est un peu vaste mais je
dirais que Total à de nouveaux projets
pétrolier au Surinam en namiie ils sont
actifs aussi au mosan
donc dans des territoires qui sont où
les États sont souvent pauvres et
corrompus et donc c'est souvent là où
total va faire affaire là où d'autres
entreprises pétrolières étrangère
refusent se refuse
donc je suivrai de de près les les
prochaines activités total dans dans ces
régions j'ai pas entendu le début de ta
phrase parce que j'étais concentré
disais que Total avait plusieurs
nouveaux projet pétrolier onshore et
offshore en namiie en Mozambique et au
Surinam donc des pays qui sont pas
connus pour leur grande
euh stabilité et aussi qui sont un peu
corrompu on peut le dire voir carrément
total va pas
corrompre ça c'est j'espère que non bon
question Internet est-ce qu'il y a une
vraie indépendance journalistique entre
parenthèses éditorial en France point
d'inrogation et la suite c'est pour
Quentin où est-ce que se situe la France
en terme de liberté de la presse par
rapport aux autres pays alors ça c'est
une vaste question qui m'a qui m'a qui
qui me hante depuis un moment euh en
tant que journaliste depuis depuis 10
ans donc j'ai pas une carrière non plus
très très longue mais je suis jeune et
donc je me suis posé beaucoup de
questions sur sur ce métier et sur le
métier que j'exerçais est-ce qui valait
la peine d'être exercé euh parce que on
a quand on est journaliste oui on a
beaucoup de bâtons dans les roues on a
un problème financiers quand on est
pigiste les médias vont pas toujours
très très bien les jour no papier
surtout donc il y a des problèmes de de
de de finance donc de finance des
enquêtes parce que les enquêtes ça prend
du temps de des finances de reportage
parce que ça coûte cher d'aller loin et
cetera de se déplacer donc il y a cette
partie financière et puis il y a
pourquoi on fait ce métier euh je pense
qu'il y a beaucoup de journalistes tu
peux t'arrêter ouais est-ce que il y a
des problèmes d'autocensure des
problèmes de ménage des problèmes de
faire plaisir à son quiip patron qui lui
va faire plaisir à son moyen patron qui
lui va faire plaisir à son grand patron
est-ce qu'il y a tout ça et est-ce que
tu sens dans ta profession qu'il y a des
journalistes tête brûlé prêts à se
sacrifier pour le sujet ou est-ce qu'ils
sont tellement en laiss parce qu'il y a
le loyer à payer la bouffe à payer
l'école des gamins à payer à le crédit à
rembourser qu'il y a une précarité dans
le dans le dans le métier que en gros on
s'arrange avec ce qu'on peut s'arranger
quoi alors ça dépend ça dépend pour ça
ça dépend des journaux on a repéré des
journalistes qui faisaient un peu trop
de ménage ah oui ça ça arrive
malheureusement il y en a beaucoup et il
y a il y a il y a on a repéré quelques
journalistes qui aimait
bien faire des dossiers à charge parce
que ça plaisait alors moi je j'avais à
un moment donné commencer une enquête
que j'ai pas j'ai pas terminé pour
plusieurs raisons euh où j'avais trouvé
un média enfin l'espèce de de de site
internet où on pouvait louer un
journaliste pour un ménage pour faire un
ménage pour animer une conférence
n'importe laquelle ah bah mince pas
nettoyer les TR se trouvait qu'il y
avait beaucoup de de journalistes télé
un peu star présentateurs moi j'appelle
pas ça vraiment des journalistes mais
bon déjà ça dit quelque chose
c'est-à-dire que ces gens en plus de
leur métier vont animer des conférences
de grandes entreprises oui mais
attention parfois il y a
des des conflits d'intérêt sur certains
sujets je v pas rentrer dans le détail
mais mais quand on voit que certains
journalistes se sont très productifs sur
certains
sujets ils ont des des données ils sont
des connaissances soudaines surt des
sujets très techniques et que on les
voit animer des conférences donner des
ménages pour ces entreprises qui sont
proche euh ça pose un problème éthique
est-ce que tu as déjà vu des
journalistes qui remplissaient une
commande commande c'est-à-dire bah tu
leur passes un coup de fil tu dis bon
lui il nous enmê un peu fais-liui un bon
papier bien CCRA non alors ça ça a des
petites tournures de phras qui vont bien
ça non ça non après il y a des
journalistes qui ont des petites dents
personnelles contre certains politiques
certains certaines personnalités là ça
va se ressentir dans le papier mais
c'est moi moi j'ai pas constaté ça après
moi j'ais évoluent en groupe ou est-ce
que c'est la déontologie journalistique
en priorité oou ils ont des petits
groupes d'intérêt ils ont des petites
accontance politique alors moi je je je
je je vais j'ai j'ai regardé euh un film
qui m'a fait beaucoup douter c'était
l'année dernière et qui m'a fait douter
sur ma profession j'étais en pleine
enquête sur total et d'ailleurs
j'attendais de voir si un média all l'a
publié pour voir si je continuais ou pas
ce métier
euh ce film là c'est les nouveaux chien
de
garde qui a été réalisé par Serge Alimi
et ses ses ses collègues de du mond
Diplo ça m'a fait beaucoup douter parce
que finalement moi je me rends compte
enfin après avoir vu ce film mais je
pense queon peut s'en rendre compte tous
que dans la alors je vais pas dire tous
les médias parce que j'englobe jamais
tous les médias il y a toujours plus de
nuances et de complexité mais dans
beaucoup de de de de de support
médiatique télé radio journaux il y a
jamais une remise en cause du système de
là à renverser la table jamais on va
aller chercher un économiste euh un
sociologue euh un expert en politique
quelqu'un qui va avoir une espèce de
vision et une pensée
qui permettrait de remettre en cause
profondément le système on va toujours
chercher des économistes qui vont
relativiser le libre échange qui vont
trouver des excuses à la crise de 2008
qui vont donner des explications et
cetera et et et en fait il y a un espèce
de nivellement du discours les conflits
géopolitiques c'est la même chose il y a
un espèce de nivellement dans les dans
dans dans les discours liés à l'économie
à la géopolitique à la politique où
euh finalement ce nivellement là il est
organisé ça c'est sûr et certain non tu
penses qu'il est organisé non non mais
il est organisé pas par l' espèce d'une
sphère complotiste qui gérerait tout
mais c'est juste que aujourd'hui forcé
de constater que les les les les les les
médias qui sont tenus sont tenus par des
milliardaires des
philanthrope philanthrope des
milliardaires qui ont à peu près tous
peu au prou la même vision
du système d'un système capitaliste
d'enrichissement de de de de où il y
aurait aucune remise en cause profonde
de de de ce système qui produit beaucoup
d'inégalité aujourd'hui et et moi je je
je l'ai vu je l'ai constaté euh par
exemple pendant la la les les
manifestation contre la réforme des
retraites j'ai vu un grand actionnaire
enfin un grand actionnaire un patron de
presse je vais pas dire son nom parce
que voilà qui est à la tête de plusieurs
médias français et qui était invité à un
grand plateau d'une grande
émission du service public et il est sur
son siège c'est un grand essayiste il a
été PDG de de grandes entreprises et
puis aussi il a grenouillé dans comme je
l'ai dit dans beaucoup de médias qui
sont pas considérés des comme étant des
médias à droite hein même plutôt à
gauche hein et première chose qu' dit
quand on l'interroge sur la réforme des
retraites c'est français travaille pas
assz selon lui c'était le problème
c'était les Français travaillent pass
assé donc on a quelqu'un qui a toujours
été à la tête de grands médias et qui
tient ce discours là y compris à la tête
de médias de gauche et donc quand vous
avez des gens qui tiennent les cordons
de la bourse parce que lui tient les
cordons de la bourse de ces de ces
grands médias qui a quand même un avis
sur les recrutements sur sur sur l'
orientation que prend les magazines et
que cette personneelà donne enfin son
opinion et son opinion qui est très
libéral vous pouvez penser que les
grande partie des médias qui sont tenus
par ces ces grands patrons de presse
ont à peu près
une si vous voulez un message un message
qui est LCÉE et qui est toujours à peu
près le le le
même question internet tout ce qu'il
dénonce au final ce n'est juste ce n'est
juste que la responsabilité du
gouvernement yéménite la responsabilité
du du du gouvernementménite que fait la
police la responsabilité est partagée
total on leura pas je te le rappel oui
oui oui moi je je dis en fonction de des
des des des documents que j'ai total on
leur a pas mis un fling sur la temp en
leur disant vous
allez construire ces installations de
sorte que elles V vont polluer les sols
et les eaux potentiellement pendant
pendant plusieurs dizaines d'années
voire décennies voire centaines d'années
donc on les a pas forcé à vouloir faire
des des des
économies on les a pas forcé c'est total
qui a eu cette cette volonté pour
réduire les coûts de production
pétroliers de les de cette plateforme au
Yémen question internet un avis sur le
financement public dont bénéficient
certains médias ne pourrait-on pas
arrêter de leur donner des subventions
alors ça non parce que il y a beaucoup
de médias qui ont besoin de ces
subvention pour de ces subventions pour
subsister je prends l'exemple de
Marianne
ou de l'OPS qui touche des subventions
publiques tous les ans sans Marian et
sans l'OPS moi je publie où mes enquêtes
sur total donc ces subventions ont
besoin ces médias ont besoin de de de
ces subventions aujourd'hui demain comme
certains hommes politiques ont proposé
si vous euh si vous arrêtez si vous
stopper les subventions au service
public si vous mettez fin à France
interre à France Culture et cetera qui
va prendre la paroleance culture bah oui
il faut surtout pas mettre fin à France
Culture si si vous stoppez C ces canaux
public si vous les les les politiseer
encore davantage à la fin on va ça ne
sera que de la communication
communication de Patrick pouyanet
communication de ellisabeth borne
communication de ça sera que de la
communication et on sait très bien que
la communication c'est pas toujours la
vérité donc les journalistes et les
médias ont besoin de ces aides pour
continuer à produire de l'information et
à produire des révélations parce que moi
je fais ce métier pour faire des
révélations et des révélations pas des
révélations sur un tel politique qui
couche avec un tel ou des révélations
putassières non des révélations qui ont
un intérêt pour le public qui ont un
intérêt pour euh le collectif euh qui
vont dénoncer des choses qui sont euh
qui sont qui sont scandaleuses donc le
le moi je fais je considère que le
travail que j'essaie en tout cas
j'essaie de produire un travail de
service public pour le service public
français pour le public français pour le
public yeménite pour le public irakien
pour le public iranien et cetera tu as
prévenu ta patronne avant de venir là ce
soir euh la direction est
prévenue question internet comment font
les médias ne touchant pas de subvention
comme nous alors alors ça c'est une
bonne question et on p 20 % de TVA tout
de suite alors ça c'est une bonne
question j'ai du mal à à répondre à ça
comment font les les les les les petits
médias qui touchent énormément
d'audiences he d'ailleurs il sont pas
petits vous je vois qu'il y a des des
centaines de de milliers de vues sur vos
sur vos vidéos euh c'est c'est difficile
à dire je j'ai pas j'ai pas trop de de
réponse là on va laisser deux trois
questions se poser encore est-ce que tu
as un sujet que tu
souhaiterais aborder avec nous parce que
il y a un sujet que tu as pas abordé tu
aimerais parler tu aimerais t'exprimer
sur le sujet ou même autre chose je te
pose une autre question quelle est son
opinion sur Daniel krittinski
propriétaire de Marianne tu t'aurais dû
répondre plus
vite on verra plus tard alors pour pour
ouais pour
là on a parlé des de la guerre des
pollutions et cetera mais le Yemen c'est
le le selon moi selon ma sensibilité le
plus beau pays du monde donc un petit
Opinel un petit canif alors pas un canif
ni un Opinel c'est un Jia c'est un
couteau un peu courbé qui est une qui
est un apparat traditionnel du du nord
du pays tu sais pourquoi il est comme ça
en forme de cross de hockey non pas pour
enlever des capsules en tout cas
décapsuler une bière mais oui le le le
Yémen est le plus beau pays du monde
euh il a selon toi le Yémen est le plus
là par contre il y a toutes les preuves
non non c'est il a il y a il y a un
héritage
historique incroyable
archéologique archéologique
archéologique incroyable non mais il y a
il y a l'ancien empire de la reine de
Saba l'empire de marine de himl les les
les le le le plus grand le plus grand
barrage de l'époque antique et le
premier barrage c'est le barrage de de
Marib on en parle dans le Coran il est
encore là le barrage il y a la ville de
Sana qui a une alors moi j'ai jamais pu
l' vooir malheureusement mais qui a une
architecture fantastique
ouais des petites tours comme ça avec
avec des Vitros de tes les couleurs il y
a Aden aussi un charme fou de cette
ville qui a été construite par les
Anglais par les par les Indiens il y a
des paysages à couper le souffle qui
changent du tout au tout en fonction
d'une région à une autre enfin c'est
c'est un
pays magique magnifique avec une avec
des un héritage culturel et des
identités tellement variées donc moi
j'aimerais lui rendre hommage parce
qu'on en parle souvent à travers le
prisme de la guerre des armes vous tapez
Yemen sur Google vous tombez que sur des
des fanatiques voilà en kalashnikov des
des chars alors que c'est le plus beau
pays du monde et les yeménites sont
incroyable moi j'ai jamais eu de de
problèmes sécuritaire j'ai toujours eu
des petites des petit moment de tension
mais c'est tu as eu peut-être beaucoup
de chance
oui et
non je veux croire en l'humain tu
t'étais un peu grimé tu t'étais un petit
peu Chéché non je me je me déguise je me
déguise jamais j'aime pas
ça question internet d'ailleurs qui qui
va rebondir sur beaucoup de choses
peut-il faire l'autocritique de sa
profession notamment sur le fait
d'utiliser les humanitaires comme moyen
d'accès ou tromper les autorités les
groupes armés ne pense-t-il pas ne
pense-t-il pas qu'il porte atteinte
infinie aux actions humanitaires et aux
efforts de développement pointinrogation
et donc aux populations civile point
d'inrogation non c'est c'est euh des
journalistes qui ont trahi euh des
forces militaires avec qui elles étaient
mettant en danger des soldats qui ont
trahi des humanitaires avec qui ils
étaient en ne disant pas exactement les
les missions qu'ils allaient faire sur
place c'est grave c'est pas éthique et
ça ne devrait pas exister parce que ça
met en péril des soldats ça met en péril
des humanitaires et leurs actions donc
ça c'est quelque chose que je je n'ai
jamais fait et c'est quelque chose que
je je condamne totalement donc ça c'est
le le le la personne qui a posé cette
question à à la vraie
là-dessus question internet pouvez-vous
nous indiquer un ou deux journalistes
exemplaires en France au cours des 20
dernières années monsieur Müller des
journalistes qui ont eu le courage de
questionner le système je trouve que
miaap part qu' font c'est c'est fort est
fortf est très fort plinel plel il a des
choses à se reprocher mais reprocher je
je pas rentrer dans les détails je suis
pas pour soit en dit pas assz soit en
dit trop je dis rien alors d'accord il a
rien à se reprocher si tu creuses pas il
a rien à se reprocher c'est je je je
vraiment je loue miaapart et je loue
plinel pour pour ce travail de publique
alors parfois certains peuvent penser
que bon c'est un petit peu à charge ça
justifie pas toujours une enquête moi je
trouve que la plupart du temps c'est
toujours des enquêtes qui sont béton qui
sont très solides et qui sont d'utilité
publique et il y en a peu des journaux
et des journalistes qui font ça en
France aujourd'hui Robert il l'a bien
fait Robert il a
évidemment non mais il y a des
journalistes évidemment qui ont fait
beaucoup et qui continuent de publier
des enquêtes d'utilité publique dans
d'autres médias que Médi part
ça c'est ça c'est clair et net donc je
mais mes médiap part je trouve que ils
font un vrai travail d'utilité publique
vraiment et il y a d'autres journaux qui
et médias qui ne font pas de
l'investigation et pas des des des
révélations fracassante mais qui
document des régions du monde qui sont
très peu documenté avec une précision et
avec un travail d'orfèvre le Monde Diplo
pour moi c'est le meilleur média de
France et le Monde Diplo ils sont bien
il y a pas a pas à dire le monde diplose
c'est quand on lit des papiers on
apprend on apprend des choses les
papiers sont longs sont carrés c'est pas
que des journalistes qui les écrivent
d'ailleurs c'est aussi des des
chercheurs des universitaires et c'est
impeccable mon Diplo moi je le je leur
tire mon chapeau il y a Orient 21 qui
fait un super travail sur le
Moyen-Orient de documentation Afrique 21
aussi pareil c'est tout ça c'est un peu
le le même microcosme press anglosaxon
en presse anglo-saxon le Guardian
Guardian oui mais oui oui oui Guardian
moins mais mais le Guardian oui oui
c'est c'est bien c'est pas Guardian
Guardian on dit Guardian Guardian c'est
c'est faux de dire Guardian
effectivement c'est
Guardian on dit coucou à notre ami de
NIM qui nous a appris à prononcer
correctement Guardian Guardian et quoi
d'autre enpr
anglosaxon je je lis j'avoue que je lis
je lis peu la presse anglsaxon non newor
Times fait souvent des des choses bien
aussi on peut pas le leur jeter la
pierre alors sur certains sur certaines
thématiques euh là le conflit
israëlo-palestinien c'est assez
déséquilibré c'est dommage mais on peut
pas le leur jeter la pierre parce que
parfois il y a des reportages qui sont
sérieux et solides he et des enquêtes
aussi euh un commentaire sur les frappes
américaines au Yémen en janvier question
Internet les outils ont bomb l'Arabie
saoudite a bombardé les outils sans
cesse en faisant des des des victimes
collatérales bombarde avec quoi avec des
canons mine fr a av des avion France non
des obus français ah des obus français
français ça c'était sorti ça Ava été
révélé par euh comment il s'appelle ce
ce ce cet organisme de d'enquête j'ai
oublié
le non un organisme d'enquête
journalistique j'ai j'ai j'ai oublié B
non français un conglomérat
euh tac tac tac tac bon j'ai oublié mais
bref c'est pas moi qui est sorti cette
info elle a été bétonnée et les la
France avait vendu beaucoup d'obus à
l'Arabie Saoudite qui on a tiré beaucoup
sur via des avions sur des cibles euh
outils et donc c'est pas depuis 2015 à
les bombardements sont arrêtés à peu
près en
2021 c'est pas ça qui a fait fléchir les
outils c'est pas des bombardements qui
vont les les les les les arrêter donc
c'est une stratégie qui
est qui est mauvaise et d'ailleurs tous
les stratégies de bombardement de de
groupuscule n'ont jamais donné lieu à
quoi que ce soit et surtout des
bombardements américains l'arithmétique
de la rébellion c'est très bien
expliqué pas un général sur une le
général Didier castre sur notre chaîne
on vous recommande chosement cette
interview est-ce que tu as trois
bouquins à conseiller à notre communauté
sur le Yemen sur ce que tu veux sur le
Yemen ouais là si il y a des des gens
qui veulent lire sur le yemmen il y a
trois bouquins formidables euh c'est
le livre de Claude La Farge et de
gordian troller qui s'appelle Yemen une
révolution
1962 donc ça qui a un livre d'archive
extraordinaire et qui explique ce
qu'elle Yemen il y a des photos des
vieilles photos aussi à l'intérieur
magnifique bouquin il y a un livre de
Sami d'orlian qui est un ancien
chercheur qui est parti qui a étudié les
outil qui a étudié ce qu ce que comment
ils sont ils se sont imposés dans le
nord du Yémen donc un livre de Sami
d'orlian qui s'appelle la
révolution j'ai oublié le le le titre
mais ça vous pourrez trouver assez
facilement avec via le nom de l'auteur
et euh il y a un livre
de de Laurent Bonnefoi qui s'appelle
Yémen de l'Arabie heureuse à la guerre à
la guerre civile qui est récent et qui
est un livre qui explique
bien comment le Yemen est a basculé dans
la dans dans la guerre et c'est un livre
plus plus contemporain plus accessible
et qui résume très bien le conflit en
cours et il y a un très très très très
très très très beau livre que j'ai lu là
récemment qui s'appelle Warda de sonala
Ibrahim un écrivain égyptien qui raconte
également une histoire dingue d'un
écrivain donc un cet écrivain égyptien
qui tombe amoureux d'une jeune
révolutionnaire omanaise yménite c'est
dans les années 60 et euh et lui il est
arrêté par Naser parce qu'il est
communiste il est jeté en prison et
cette femme-là euh part rejoindre la
révolution d'opari omanez contre les
Britanniques et contre un sultan despot
et c'est une espèce de de de de
révolution hybride où les femmes se
rasent la tête euh combattent avec les
hommes partagent leur quotidien avec les
hommes dans ces montagnes et pendant
plus de 15 ans ils vont tenir tête aux
Britanniques et et au et et au sultan et
ils vont créer une ils vont vouloir
libérer la péninsule arabique de
l'emprise anglaise et ça c'est une
révolution qui a eu beaucoup de d'impact
à l'époque qui a été soutenu par le
Yémen socialiste qui a été soutenu par
plein de jeunes qui ont sacrifié leur
vie parce qu'ils avaient des idéos
panarabistes marxistes communistes qui
ont rejoint cette révolution et euh et
et en fait lui par la essayer de
retrouver cette femme qui a disparu
parce que la révolu ution a pris fin et
dans les années 90 il récupère il
retrouve des vieux carnets de des
carnets de de intime de cette femme qui
raconte cette révolution de l'intérieur
et le livre est fantastique bon avant
que tu donnes un conseil pour les jeunes
générations on espère que Total va
répondre à toutes tes questions et
éclaircir de TR oui j'en doute pas j'en
doute pas tu vas leur créer un petit peu
de stress avec ta prochaine enquête qui
va sortir là non j'espère enfin j'espère
non mais je s'ils ont des des des choses
à à se reprocher j'espère qu'ils seront
honnêtes avec moi et qu'ils finiront par
avouer parce que ce qu'on n' pas dit là
c'est que quand même il y a un procès
qui est en cours suite à mes révélations
c'est que suite à mes révélations il y a
des victimes que j'avais rencontré sur
place qui se sont organisé au Yémen qui
sont plus de 120 aujourd'hui et qui ont
saisi un avocat en France et l'avocat a
saisi la justice il y a deux procédures
en cours contre Total euh et qui ont il
y a eu une première séance là en février
et ça ira sur le fond certainement cet
été et sur la base de mes révélations et
mes mes documents donc cette action en
justice elle est pas enfin ce qui prouve
que mon enquête n'est pas
branlante est-ce que tu as un conseil
pour les jeunes générations une
bouteille à la mer quelque chose
d'impérissable pour les jeunes
générations je dirais qu'il
faut faut pas avoir peur faut pas avoir
peur de de s'attaquer à gros parfois
quand on est béton quand on a des choses
à dire quand on a des choses à dénoncer
et quand il faut s'indigner là où il
faut s'indigner faut le faire faut pas
avoir peur faut pas tergiverser et être
plat passer des plats être dans la
tiédeur moi je c'est pas ce que je c'est
pas ce que je veux et ce que je ce que
je veux pour les nouvelles générations
c'est qu'ell c'est qu'elles aient
toujours des flammes qui qui sortent de
la bouche des choses à dire et quand les
choses à dire quand quand les choses
elles méritent d' d'être dites il faut
qu'elle faut qu'ell sorte Quentin müer
merci merci à
[Musique]
vous